TO THE ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE HEARING
OF JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE'S SO.
ARE THESE ALL THE GRIEVING
HOUSEKEEPING NO HAVE GREAT NO
HOUSEKEEPING --
SO.
THEN WE DON'T WANT CALL CUANDO
LATER SO --
CENTER BRADFORD.
YOU'D LIKE.
TO GET STARTED IT WITH S. B..
SOMETHING OR OTHER.
FORGOTTEN WERE REALLY READY
TWELVE FIFTY WHILE FIFTY TWELVE
FIFTY SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ASK STATED I'M HERE TO
PRESENT S. B..
TWELVE FIFTY WHICH IS A ISSUE
JUST CLARIFYING EXISTING LAWS
ARE RELATES TO DOMICILE OF A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE US.
CONGRESS AND IT'S A CONCLUSIVE
PERSON ARE PRESUMED TO BE THE
ADDRESS WHERE THEY ARE
REGISTERED TO VOTE AS LONG AS
ADDRESSES AND ACTUAL RESIDENTS.
OF THE MEMBERS CURRENT ARE
DEFINED BY CURRENT LAW SHOULD
SAY.
BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE UNIQUE JOB
THAT --
LEGISLATORS DO WE TRAVEL AND AND
WORKING IN AND OUTSIDE OUR
DISTRICTS ON A REGULAR BASIS
SPENDINGMUCH OF THE YEAR AT THE
STATE CAPITOL.
EXISTING LAW ESTABLISHES THAT
THE DOMICILE OF A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
OR REPRESENTATIVE CONGRESS
UNITED STATES SHOULD BE
CONCLUSIVELY PARTS PRESUMED TO
BE THE ADDRESS INDICATED ON THE
PERSON'S CURRENT CURRENTLY
FOLLOWED. FOR REGISTRATION.
SPIKE THIS CONCLUSION OZ SAT IN
STATUEBACK IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR QUARTS HAVE MISINTERPRETED
OR IGNORED.
PLAIN LANGUAGE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF THE LAW
THIS BILL SIMPLY RESTATE WHAT
LEGISLATIVE INTENT AREAS.
ARE S. B. TWELVE FIFTY DOES NOT
EXPAND OR CHANGE RESIDENCY FOR
ANY CURRENT PAST OR FUTURE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE THIS
BILL THE PRODUCT OF MANY MEANS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
ARE MEMBERS OF THE ELECTIONS
ELECTION COMMITTEE AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION IMAGE RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF SUPPORT
RESPECT LESS WORRY AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD --
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SINGING ON ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK A
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIOS OR
COMMENTS.
HIS HANDS ON EARTH HE HAS HIGH
CENTER BRADFORD MARC STEINORTH
HOW ARE YOU FUN JUST WANTED TO
VERIFY THAT THIS LEGISLATION IS
STRICTLY TO CUT A FIVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE AT THE THE APPELLATE
COURT'S DECISION AS LISTED HERE
PEOPLE V. SUPERIOR COURT RIGHT.
TO THAT THIS CO DEFIES THE
APPELLATE COURT DECISION THAT
THE INTENTION OF YOUR
LEGISLATION THAT INTENTIONALLY
LUGGAGE LEGISLATION IS TO
RESTATE --
SECTION ELECTION COLD --
TWENTY TWENTY SIX THAT HAS BEEN
IN EXISTENCE FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS IT JUST.
CLARIFY WHAT DOMICILE VERSES
RESIDENCIA.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD SO
WOULD YOU LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE -- AYE
I THINK INDUSTRY FORD MANAGER
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
VOTE WHEN YOU KNOW CALL.
APPRECIATE THAT WE DON'T KNOW
CORMIER BUT WHEN WE DO WE'LL
HAVE YES RECOMMENDATION THANK
YOU APPRECIATE ANY MEMBERS
.
MISTER BERMAN IS GOING TO
PRESENT HIS BILL.
AB.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ND COLLEAGUES I
COME BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TO
PRESENT AB.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH
WOULD IMPROVE VOTER FILE
SECURITY IN COMBAT VOTER
MISINFORMATION.
WHEN THIS BILL WAS PREVIOUSLY
HEARD BY THIS COMMITTEE ADDRESS
A DIFFERENT SUBJECT IN HIS BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERATION OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS?
FIRST THIS BOARD DIRECTED
SECRETARY OF STATE TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS THAT DESCRIBE BEST
PRACTICES.
STORAGE AND SECURITY OF VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION AS WELL
AS REQUIRE PERSON OR ENTITY WHO
HAS RECEIVED ACCESS TO VOTER
INFORMATION. TO DISCLOSE ANY
DATA BREACH TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
SECOND AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
WOULD COMBAT DECEPTIVE VOTER
PRACTICES CURRENT LAW ONLY
PROHIBITS THE DISSEMINATION OF
MISINFORMATION REGARDING A
VOTERS POLLING PLACE.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE LAWN
ENCOMPASS THE DISTRIBUTION OF
FALSE INFORMATION REGARDING THE
TIME PLACE OR MANNER OF VOTING
AND WOULD INCLUDE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF SUCH
MISINFORMATION VIA THE INTERNET
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
AND WITH NEEDED IS TIPPING OFF
IN THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SECRETARY OF STATE A I MEAN
TIPPING WELCOME BEHALF OF
SECRETARY SAID ALEX VIDEA AND
WE'RE PROUD SPONSOR THIS BILL.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY OTHER OF
PERSONS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
OTHER PERSONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
PEOPLE STAND STATE STANCE THAT.
WASN'T REAL.
YEAH OKAY YOU TO GET YOUR NAME
AND WHAT DO YOU REPRESENT.
YEAH I'M ANDREAS FISCHER WITH
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIANS TRY.
ANY OTHER SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
THING OPPOSITION ANY MEMBERS.
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THIS.
OKAY A YOU WERE CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE WHEN
THERE'S A FORM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND CAN
[inaudible]
ANNOUNCED
.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM PRESENT MADAM SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BERMAN.
ARE HERE BERMAN HERE HARPER
[inaudible]
CALDERON LOW [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN HERE STEINORTH STEINORTH
HERE WEBER WEBER HERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOW WE JUST NEED SOME AUTHORS.
AND SO WE'VE HEARD CHIU BILLS --
BEFORE WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM THE
COMMITTEE HEARD CENTER BRADFORD
ON S. B. --
TWELVE FIFTY I'M RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT IS THERE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY HE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE HARPER
[inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
THOUGH [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THAT'S OUT AND WILL KEEP IT OPEN.
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND ON
AND SAT ON A FOUR ZERO VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SO WE
WERE MOTION AND THE SECOND ON A.
B. SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
BERMAN --
BERMAN IS RECOMMENDING I VOTE
NONE OF SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS WITH
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED AND BERMAN.
I BERMAN AYE HARPER [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
THOUGH [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THAT'S ARE OUT FORO WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THAT
ON AND NOW WE STILL NEED AUTHORS
[inaudible]
WHO
YES SIR [inaudible]
THEY THANK YOU APOLOGIZE ABOUT.
NOT AT ALL SENATOR DOLE IT'S
ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO HAVE YOU
HERE UP LATE.
I BET WE WERE.
YEAH I HEARD FROM THE HANNAH
BETH THAT YOU DON'T SLEEP SO DE
LAID UP EARLY IN THEIR OWN.
ANSWER THAT'S A RUMOR.
CENTER HERTZBERG PRESENTING SP.
TWELVE THIRTY NINE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY SIR.
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
HOPE THERE.
REALLY GOOD BECAUSE I HAVE READ
AND THEY REALLY ARE IT'S GOOD
THE BEST BUT SINCE YOU'RE THE
CHAIR OF CEZANNE AND I TRUST.
NO PROBLEM.
SO YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CALLIXTUS.
ARMS SECTOR STATE WEBSITE IT'S
IT IT IS IN A TIME OF
MODERNIZATION OF THE WORLD WHAT
WE ALL HAVE THESE FUNNY THINGS.
AND IN A POCKET AND THE WAY WE
INTERFACE WITH EVERYBODY YOU
KNOW ITS SUCH UNBELIEVABLE AND
SO THE CHALLENGE WE DO IS IT IT
WE TALK ABOUT HERE IS.
TO IS TO MODERNIZE THE SYSTEM
MAKE IT EASIER FOR FOLKS ON IT
AT AND THE LIKE IN FACT IF YOU
RECALL THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S
PROCESS WHO ARE GRAPPLING WITH
NOW. 1-253- OF PULLING MEASURES
OFF THE BALLOT WE ACTUALLY HAD
IT NEGOTIATIONS AS YOU HEAR
WAGON.
AND THE COMPROMISE LEGISLATION
WAS THE LEGISLATION THEY OFTEN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WHICH WAS
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE PUT SOME
MONEY IN THE BUDGET AND START
MOVING TOWARD.
THIS MODERNIZATION OF CALYX
ISSUE OR FACING NOW IS CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION FEE WILL WITH SECTOR
STATES OFFICE THAT THEY NEED. TO
TAKE IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL TO
MAKE THIS IS.
PROUD ABOUT THIS AND ALL OF US
ARE ABLE TO GET INFORMATION
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S TOUGH YOU KNOW
JUST THAT SIMPLE SO WITH THAT I
WILL TURN OVER THE SECULAR
STATES OFFICE.
IS MUCH SMARTER THAN ME IN THIS
[inaudible]
NEGATIVE.
DID A MOCK UP BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE HOME.
AS NOTED WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS CLEAN UP LANGUAGE TO
IMPLEMENT THEM. THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE AND PERCENT I HAVE HIGHLY
WAGNER HERE ALSO TO HELP WITH
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU PHILIP ON THE BEHALF A
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WHEN A WOMAN VOTERS A CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR MOTIONS ARE SECONDS.
A TOUGH CROWD WE GOT A MOTION.
ALL SECOND IT [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU --
THE CENTERS FOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT YOU KNOW
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT DON'T LOOK LIKE THEY'RE BIG
DEALS BUT I THINK IN TERMS OF
HOW WE AS GOVERNMENT INTERFACE
WITH THE FOLKS.
AND THE WORK THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE AND IS DOING AND
I THINK WE CAN BE PRETTY PROUD
OF THIS OF THIS EFFORT AND DOES.
ITS AGAIN IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A
GIGANTIC BILL BUT IT ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS IN TERMS OF THIS ISSUE
THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR
FOURTY YEARS ABOUT DISCLOSURE IN.
CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND ALL THIS
STUFF THIS IS KIND OF ONE OF
THOSE COMPONENTS THAT STUCK.
PRETTY IMPORTANT IN THIS LARGER
OF DISCUSSIONS I APPRECIATED AND
ASK YOU ABOUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND I AGREE
ENSURING THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS
TO KEEP IN FINANCE DATA THAT IS
TRANSPARENT AND USER FRIENDLY IS
VITAL. TO THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS THE CAL ACCESS SYSTEM
IS ANTIQUATED IS HAMPERED OUR
ABILITY TO MODERNIZE CAMPAIGN
FINANCE POLICIES AND FULFILL OUR
OBLIGATIONS.
UNDER THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT
IN THIS BILL WILL HELP
FACILITATE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE NEW CAMPAIGN AND LOBBYING
DISCLOSURE SYSTEM.
THAT WILL BE UP AND RUNNING
SOMETIME NEXT YEAR SO I AM HAPPY
TO RECOMMEND SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTIONS.
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE HARPER
[inaudible]
CALDERON.
LOW.
MULLIN MULLIN AYE STEINORTH
STEINORTH AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE THEM BILLS OUT ON A
FOR A VOTE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AS CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PUSH IT VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SENATOR.
AND NEXT UP WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER WITH ITEM
NUMBER TWO A CA.
SIXTEEN WILL GIVE YOU A MINUTE
TO SET UP A THE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU SIR.
DOES IT SHOW THE BAY IT AS SAN
FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES IS THE
SAME SIZE.
NO NOT NOT THIS ON EARNED.
SO MAYBE YOU JUST [inaudible]
A PICTURE.
WHOLE AM THERE GOES.
THAT GO DOWN NO [inaudible]
IT.
THOSE A LITTLE FORESHADOWING I
THINK.
I'M [inaudible]
OKAY --
PLEASE SIR.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN --
YOU APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PREP PRESENT ACA --
SIXTEEN WHICH IS WOULD
ESSENTIALLY REFORM THE STATE
SENATE -- TO
PROVIDE FOR MORE EQUALITY OF OF
REPRESENTATION AMONG THE REGIONS
OF CALIFORNIA AND SO.
IF YOU WERE TO LOOK AT THIS
VISUAL WHAT WE DO IS.
AS WE DIVIDE THE STATE INTO
EIGHT SEPARATE REGIONS AND THAT
I THINK YOU KNOW AND AND AND ONE
OF THINGS UP POINT OUT AS YOU
KNOW I'M NOT I'M CITY NOT TIED
TO THIS EXACT.
FORMAT BUT I WANT HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE
MODERNIZE OUR REPRESENTATION IN
THE STATE --
BUT WITH THE WAY WE PROPOSE TO
DO THIS IS TO DIVIDE THE STATE
AND EIGHT REGIONS THAT I THINK.
REFLECT THE THE DIFFERENT SUB
REGION SAID YOU KNOW AND IN SOME
WAYS YOU COULD THINK OF SUB
STATES.
OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT REFLECT
ITS ITS DIVERSITY OF OF
INDUSTRIES OF OF CULTURE A OF
REGIONS AND ALLOWS EACH OF THOSE
REGIONS TO HAVE AN EQUAL PLACE
AT THE TABLE.
IN THE STATE SENATE'S OF EACH
REGION.
WHAT ELECT FIVE STATE SENATORS
AND?
IT'S MORE REFLECTIVE OF OF WHAT
WE WOULD CALL THE FEDERAL MODEL --
A OF THE LEGISLATURE WHERE YOU
HAVE ONE HOUSE BASED COMPLETELY
ON POPULATION IN ONE HOUSE --
PROVIDING FOR EQUALITY OF OF
REPRESENTATION AMONG THE STATES
IN THE CASE OF THE U. S.
GOVERNMENT --
HERE WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
THESE EIGHT REGIONS --
SO LOOK I'M YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS PROBABLY.
NOT SOMETHING THAT'S LOOKED --
YOU KNOW VERY HIGHLY UPON BY THE
THEM ESPECIALLY IN THE MORE
URBAN PARTS.
A OF CALIFORNIA BUT WHAT I WOULD
ASK YOU IS.
TO AT LEAST REFLECT UPON --
REPRESENTATION AND WHAT THAT
REALLY MEANS YOU KNOW IS IT JUST
BASED ON POPULATIONS POPULATION
SOLELY WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REPRESENTATION I WOULD ARGUE
THAT IT'S NOT IN FACT?
OUR FOUNDERS ACTUALLY POINTED
THAT OUT --
IN THE FEDERALIST PAPERS.
WHEN THEY SAID ABOUT IT IN
RELEVANT PART AND IT IS OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE IN A REPUBLIC NOT
ONLY TO GUARD?
THE SOCIETY AGAINST THE
OPPRESSION OF ITS RULERS.
BUT TO GUARD ONE PART OF SOCIETY
AGAINST THE INJUSTICE OF ANOTHER
PART.
DIFFERENT INTERESTS NECESSARILY
EXIST IN DIFFERENT CLASSES OF
CITIZENS IF THE MAJORITY BE
UNITED BY ONE COMMON INTEREST IN
THE INTEREST THE RIGHTS OF THE
MINORITY.
WILL BE INSECURE.
AND SO WHAT WE SET UP IN THE
FEDERAL MODEL WAS A WAVE OF
GUARDING AGAINST THAT OF HAVING
CHECKS AND BALANCES AGAINST.
OF THE TYRANNY OF OF THE WITH
THAT THERE CAN BE A TYRANNY OF
THE MAJORITY YOU KNOW WHEN OF
WHEN A MAJORITY.
AND IS EITHER TEMPERED BY --
YOU KNOW THE DEMAGOGUERY OR
OTHERWISE --
THEY CAN THEY CAN USE THAT
MAJORITY THAT ROB POWER. TWO
VIOLATE OF THE RIGHTS OF OF
MINORITIES [inaudible]
AND AND YOU KNOW I THINK THAT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
ALWAYS BE GUARDING AGAINST BUT
THE FACT OF THEMATTER HERE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA'S WE HAVE NO SUCH
GUARD.
WE ELECTED GOVERNOR BASED ON ROB
MAJORITY PLURALITY.
WE ELECT ALL OF OUR ALL OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE DISTRICTS ARE BASED
PURELY ON POPULATION AND ARE
ELECTED BY ROB POLITICAL --
PLURALITIES ARE MAJORITIES --
OUR OUR EVEN OUR JUDICIAL BRANCH
THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES ARE
UP FOR ELECTION EVERY SEVEN
YEARS.
AND THAT VOTE IS OF AGAIN A ROB
POLITICAL MAJORITY THERE IS NO.
CHECK LIKE WE HAVE WITH THE U.
S. SENATE AND OTHER THINGS THAT
WE HAVE HAD IN PLACE A IN THE US
GOVERNMENT TO HELP PROVIDE THOSE
CHECKS.
AND AND BALANCES AND I THINK
THAT'S A DEFICIENCY I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
[inaudible]
AND ONE THING THAT THE THE
CHAIRMAN AND I SHARING COMMON
ACTUALLY BUT ONE OF SEVERAL
THINGS AND IS IT.
WE BOTH HAVE IN OUR OWN
DISTRICTS BACK HOME.
PEOPLE ATTEMPTING --
TO SPLIT THE STATE.
THAT THAT WHAT THEY HAVE BECOME
THAT THAT THAT ESSENTIALLY AND
NO BREAK THAT DOWN A LITTLE BIT
PEOPLE HAVE BECOME SO
DISILLUSIONED WITH HOW THE
REPRESENTATION STRUCTURE IS SET
UP.
THAT THEY WOULD RATHER SPLIT OFF
AND FORM THEIR OWN STATE.
THEN STAY PART OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AND I THINK THAT'S A VERY
REAL FRUSTRATION AND MANY NOT
JUST IN MY DISTRICT NOT JUSTIN
IN YOUR DISTRICT BUT IN MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE PEOPLE
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEIR VOICE.
AND IS GETTING HEARD.
AND IF WE LOOK AT THE HISTORY
HERE WE HAVE OUR LEGISLATIVE
STRUCTURE.
WAS ESSENTIALLY ESTABLISHED BY
THE CONSTITUTIONAL CONVENTION OF
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND THAT
THAT IS YOU KNOW SINCE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WE HAVE NOT
CHANGED.
I REPRESENTATION STRUCTURE
ESSENTIALLY WE HAVE FORTY FORTY
SENATORS EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
THAT'S WHERE IT'S BEEN SET IN
STONE SINCE THEN.
I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT JUST IN
HISTORICAL CONTEXT.
THAT WAS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONVENTION IT WAS TAKEN OVER BY
THE WORKING MEN'S PARTY.
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND ALSO
BROUGHT US CHINESE EXCLUSION.
AND WE ALSO THERE WAS A LOT
GOING ON AND IN THAT CONTEXT
THAT YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK WAS
A VERY POSITIVE THING.
AND YET WORSE WHERE WE'RE STILL
USING THE SAME STRUCTURE THAT WE
ESTABLISHED IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SO BOOK I THINK THAT THERE
IS.
A VERY MUCH AN ARGUMENT AND FOR
US TO LOOK AT HOW WE MODERNIZE
IT MAYBE THIS ISN'T THE ANSWER
MAYBE THERE'S ANOTHER WAY TO DO
THAT -- BUT
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT --
AND ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS AS
PUBLIC PEOPLE WHO SAY YOU KNOW
LOOK WE WE ARE THEIR VOICE.
BUT EACH OF US REPRESENTS
FORKNER FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
OUR SENATORS REPRESENT ALMOST A
MILLION.
RIGHT THERE'S A LOT OF VOICES IN
THERE [inaudible]
THAT TIME.
IT'S HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
VOICE IS AT LEAST GIVE IT THAT
YOU KNOW SOME KIND OF SEAT AT
THE TABLE SOME KIND OF VOICE AND
LET ME JUST GIVE JUST SOME.
AND IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME I KNOW.
IS A YOU KNOW IF YOU WOULD
INDULGE ME AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
YEAH.
LIKE I CAN SAY THIS I KNOW THEM
THERE HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE SOME
QUESTIONS I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS BUT LET ME JUST
GIVE YOU A COUPLE EXAMPLES JUST
FROM FROM MY DISTRICT AND AS YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW. FOR A LONG TIME
UP IN THE NORTHERN PART OF THE
STATE TIMBER AND MINING WERE
VERY.
STRONG INDUSTRIAL SECTOR IT
PROVIDE A LOT OF GOOD PAYING
JOBS. FOR PEOPLE IN MY AREA.
BUT LARGELY BECAUSE OF POLICIES
SUPPORTED BY URBAN AREAS YOU
KNOW BOTH BOTH INCOMING FROM THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND THE STATE
LEVEL.
BOTH THOSE INDUSTRIES SHUT DOWN
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT HAPPENED IN
THOSE.
SHUT DOWN WE HAVE SEVERAL
GENERATIONS NOW.
AND I'M IN SOME THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT USED TO RELY ON
THAT THAT.
A OF DRUG ABUSE OF YOU KNOW
PARENTS WHO LEFT THE SITUATION
OF CHILDREN HAVE GROWN UP IN
POVERTY.
AND WITH NO OPPORTUNITIES YOU
KNOW.
AND LARGELY BECAUSE OF DECISIONS
I GOT MADE BY SOMEBODY SOMEWHERE
ELSE NOT BY PEOPLE WHO LIVE
THERE.
NOT BY PEOPLE WHO WHO EXPERIENCE
THAT.
AND THAT'S BEEN A VERY DIFFICULT
THING -- FOR
THAT REGION TO RECOVER FROM --
THE THINGS THAT WE DO HAVE AND
WE TRIED.
TO THE PLANT THERE IS IS ONE OF
THEM IS MANUFACTURING IS WE'VE
HAD A GROWING MANUFACTURING
SECTOR ESPECIALLY IN OR THOUGH
WHICH YOU GUYS HAVE HEARD A LOT
OF ABOUT --
BUT THAT MANUFACTURING GROWTH
HAS ACTUALLY BEEN HAMPERED.
VERY MUCH SO BY SOME OF OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS POLICIES.
NO MAY JUST.
END UP I REALLY THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT THING TO DRIVE HOME.
pWE HAVE PRETTY CLEAN AIR THE
NORTH STATE.
NO I THINK THERE'S ONLY ONE PART
OF MY DISTRICT IT'S IN NON
ATTAINMENT.
AND THAT'S ONLY BECAUSE HE GETS
LUMPED IN WITH SACRAMENTO --
AND THERE ARE QUALITY ISSUES AND
SO THAT'S THE ONLY PART OF MY
DISTRICT IT'S IN NON ATTAINMENT
RIGHT NOW AND THEN A
SENTIMENTALITY WOULD TELL YOU
THE SAME THING [inaudible]
AND YES SO.
WE REALLY ACTUALLY NEED THE
CARBON IF YOU WILL IN ORDER SUB
SUPPORT OUR MANUFACTURING AND
AND AND THE GROWTH THAT WE HAVE
IN THERE.
THE ONLY CARBON OUTPUT THAT WE
REALLY DO HAVE IN THE NORTH
STATE.
THAT CREATES THAT THAT ACTUALLY
CREATE SOME OF THE LARGEST
CARBON OUTPUT IS OUR FORESTS
BURNING EVERY YEAR.
NEW CREATES MORE CARBON THAN
THAN ANYTHING ELSE RIGHT.
AND WHAT WE'VE LONG ARGUED FOR
BUT WE CAN'T GET.
MOSTLY BECAUSE OF URBAN NEAR
POLICIES PASSED BY OUT OF THE
URBAN PARTS THE STATE WHO AGAIN.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T NECESSARILY
LIVE THERE.
DON'T HAVE AN INTERACTION WITH
THE FORCE DON'T KNOW A LOT OF
THE ISSUES THERE GET TO DECIDE.
HOW THAT FORCED IS MANAGED AND
IT'S LED TO THESE FORCE BECOMING
TENDER BOXES THAT BURN EVERY
YEAR?
RIGHT NOW LAST WEEK AND BUTTE
COUNTY WHERE SUPERVISOR
LAMBERTUS FROM AN UNTAMED COUNTY
WE'VE GOT FIRES MIA ONCE AGAIN.
ALL THAT THAT'S WHERE THE CARBON
OUTPUT HAS COME FROM THE
MEANWHILE.
I CAN'T OPEN UP A GLASS FACTORY
IN --
ORVILLE WHICH ACTUALLY DID THEY
WANTED TO COME IN.
BECAUSE THE COST OF PAYING
CREDITS --
WAS TOO GREAT FOR THIS COMPANIES
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE IT WORK.
AND YOU KNOW SO.
LET ME DECIDE NOTHING TO
AGRICULTURE VERY STRONG SECTOR
IN MY IN MY AREA.
WE HAD THE I GO OVER TIME BILL.
TWO YEARS AGO ANY HEARD FROM
MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
OUR CULTURE INCLUDING MYSELF
THAT SAID.
APPLYING THE SAME OVERTIME RULES
TO THIS INDUSTRY DOESN'T WORK
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT HOW WE WORK
IN AGRICULTURE WE HAVE HARVESTED
WE HAVE PLANNING TIME WHERE
THERE'S VERY LONG HOURS.
AND WE NEED TO GO LONGER HOURS
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED THE
FLEXIBILITY OF OVER TIME NOT
KICKING IN UNTIL.
OF A LONGER SET OF OURS WE HAVE
IN OUR OFF SEASON WE'RE TRYING
TO GET PEOPLE EIGHT HOURS.
YOU KNOW --
AND SO WE EXPLAIN THAT.
RIGHT BUT LARGELY DUE TO YOU
KNOW URBAN NEAR URBAN
LEGISLATORS AGAIN.
AND I'M NOT SAYING THIS IN A AM
NOT TRYING TO BE NEGATIVE ABOUT
THIS BUT IT WAS.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WORK IN THE
INDUSTRY WHO DON'T HAVE
EXPERIENCE I HAVE NEVER WORKED
ON A FARM.
WE'RE MAKING DECISIONS FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY DO
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
AND IF THEN PERHAPS IF OUR
REGION.
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY REGION --
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE REGION A OF
CALIFORNIA HAD MORE OF A VOICE
MORE OF A SAY PERHAPS THERE
WOULD MORE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
OF THOSE ISSUES.
AND SO EARLIER THIS IS WHERE I
YOU KNOW THIS IS WHERE I THINK
LOOK THERE IS A LEGITIMATE ISSUE
HERE THAT IS CAUSING PEOPLE. TO
SAY LOOK WE WANT A LEAD WE
ACTUALLY WANT TO PHYSICALLY
LEAVE THE STATE.
THAT WE SHOULD CONSIDER YOU KNOW
A NIGHT AND I THINK TO START
HERE IN THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
WHERE WE HAVE SOME VERY.
YOU KNOW SMART PEOPLE WHO THINK
ABOUT THESE ISSUES --
AND HERE'S MY PROPOSAL.
YOU HERE'S MY DRAFT HERE'S MY
TAKE ON IT I'D LIKE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND AND START MAYBE
MOVE IN A DIRECTION WE TRULY
MODERNIZE.
OUR REPRESENTATION AND GIVE ALL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA VOICE AND A
SEAT AT THE TABLE.
AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
DO HAVE.
ONE WITNESS IN SUPPORT THAT YOU
KNOW --
CHAIRMAN OF THE BUTTE COUNTY
SEAT BOARD SUPERVISORS STEVEN
EMBER FOR ABOUT A QUICKLY OR TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ALL DAY
YESTERDAY SOME OUTSIDE THE FENCE
SO I KNOW.
I'M JUST RECORD I JUST SAY NO
I'M A FIT YOUR IS CALIFORNIAN
LEGACY CALIFORNIA AND AYE
PREACHES AUTOMATE MORES AND
STOMACH I'M STILL FARMERS
MCKENNA FARMAN BICU MODOC
ANGLE AND PLUMAS COUNTY.
ARE CALTRANS INFORMED BOTH MIGHT
MY THING IS EVERY MOTHER'S
REGIONS IS DIFFERENT RIGHT AT A
FARM IN A DIFFERENT SET OF
CRITERIA.
I GUESS FOR ME IS IS WHY I DON'T
AND JAMES BROUGHT UP AT THE
URBAN A VOTE.
SLOWLY SLOWLY DIE BECAUSE OF
THAT JAMES SAID INDUSTRY'S GONE
THERE'S OVER THERE.
REAL QUICKLY IS.
I I LOOK AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS A AS A FAMILY
RIGHT WE'RE ALL FAMILY AND AND
WE WERE DIVERSE FAMILY.
AND WE'RE ONLY GOOD AS OUR
WEAKEST MEMBER IN THE FAMILY AND
IF WE KEEP.
PUTTING THIS ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE
AND I IN THE RURAL COUNTIES THAT
WATSON MIGHT AN AND IT'S SAD FOR
ME TO WATCH.
THEM TRY TO BALANCE BUDGETS TRY
THE THINGS.
ON MARIJUANA ON YOU KNOW TRY TO
DO THE MATH ISSUE TENUOUS ISSUES
YET YOU THAT THE STATE NEEDS WE
NEED THE TAX BASE OF THE BAY
AREA WE NEED TO OF OF ALLAH WE
NEED THAT TAX BASE TO KEEP OUR
SCHOOLS OPEN.
THAT'S WHY I'VE BEEN TOLD
AGAINST STATE OF JEFFERSON THAT
THAT THEY WOULD WANT TO LYNCH ME
SO BAD IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE WE'RE JUST BIGGEST
COUNTY A POPULATION WISE THEY
WANT TO BE PART OF THAT MOVEMENT --
IS UNSUSTAINABLE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT I'VE SAID THAT
OVER AND OVER OVER.
AND I THINK A FRAGMENTED.
STATE WOULD BE THE WORST THING
EVER MAY LOOK A WEST VIRGINIAN I
MEAN I DON'T WANNA BE THAT.
YEAH THAT'S LASSEN TO DO IT AYE
MY THING IS WE'VE GOT TO TAKE
CARE OF THE RURAL FOLKS AND
UNLESS WE GET URBAN LEGISLATORS
OUT TO SEE THE RURAL.
A AND REALLY TRULY UNDERSTAND WE
WERE DEALING WITH A WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE KIND OF A DRAG RIGHT WE
HAVE ALL THE RESOURCES WE HAVE
THE WATER.
WE'RE THAT DRAG ON OUR SOCIETY
THE SENSE I MEAN IN THAT COLOR
RESOURCE OF DONOR HOMELESS
PROBLEM.
BECAUSE WITH YOUR HOMELESS IF
YOU CAN FIGURE OUT IT'S PRETTY
CHEAP LEVEL WE LIVE RIGHT SET
WITH OTHER RESOURCE TO TAKE CARE
OF THAT.
SORT WE GIVE UP THAT WE GIVE UP
MEAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS WE GIVE UP.
THINGS WERE LUCKY IF YOU CAN
BECAUSE WE'RE YOU KNOW HALF A
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET WE HAVE
MONEY.
BUT ALLOCATE AROUND US AREN'T.
SO THAT WE COULD COME WITH US TO
HELP THEM DO CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES TRYING TO STOP.
ALL THESE THINGS.
THE RIPPLE EFFECT.
SO WE'RE FOR FORTUNE IMPUTE BUT
ALL KINDS RUN INTRODUCED YOU
WATCHING TO DIE.
I MEAN THEY'RE JUST OF A DYING
AND AND AND I ALWAYS SAY THAT IN
AGONY EVERYTHING ELSE.
HE WOULD UNDERSTAND WE'VE
GENERATIONS AWAY FROM RURAL YOU
KNOW PEOPLE IN URBAN AREAS IT.
NO WAY DOES ANY ORCHESTRA
COLLEGE AND EVERYTHING TOWN NOW.
YOU KNOW SO IT'S DIFFERENT IT'S
NOT LIKE IT'S AN ADVERSARIAL
THING IS JUST.
THEY UNDERSTAND IT'S NO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE IN THE IN RURAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT TAKES TO LIVE
IN URBAN AREAS YOU DON'T.
THESE THINGS OUT HE JUST BILL
THAT FENCE UP THERE JUST DO THIS
DO WHAT I THERE'S ROOM RICH
REASONABLE DUMPING INTO THE
RIVERS.
MEAN THERE'S THERE'S THINGS WE
DON'T YOU KNOW THAT'S SO I THINK
THAT THAT.
UNTIL WE HAVE THAT KIND OF TO
TAKE OF SOME SORT.
AND JAMES DONE A GREAT JOB
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT SOME WAY TO
DO THAT GIVE ATHLETES.
WE'RE GONNA STRUGGLE THE STATE
AND AND AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S WE HAVE.
SO MANY GREAT THINGS HERE I MEAN
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE PLACE AND
I I WOULD HOPE THAT.
SOME KIND OF MOVEMENT COMES
[inaudible]
THAT SO.
THANK YOU LISA RESIDENT.
NOT ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEN NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
BRING ABOUT A COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SOMEONE
REMOTE.
THEY WERE SHARON AND THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE UP. FOR YOUR
EFFORT -- I
KNOW YOU'RE PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS AND IT PUT QUITE A BIT OF
TIME -- INTO
THIS SO -- I
APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT I DO NOT
AGREE WITH --
THE POLICY.
AND THE DIRECTION YOU'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU A COUPLE PRETTY
OBVIOUS QUESTIONS THAT I'M.
HOW SURE YOU EXPECT ARE COMING
JUST -- THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY A ANGLE HERE
WITH EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE
SAID AND YOU KNOW WHAT THIS UP
YOU KNOW HOW THIS PROPOSAL.
IS VIEWED IN THE LIGHT OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND THEN ARE THERE
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE THIS KIND
OF UPPER HOUSE.
A REPRESENTATION NOW SPLIT INTO
OF VARIOUS REGIONS SERVICES SAY
HE CALIFORNIA UNIQUE --
APPROACH THAT YOU'RE TAKING.
GREAT QUESTION I WAS EXPECTING
THAT AND AND CERTAINLY --
SO AS AS YOU NOTE IN YOUR
ANALYSIS AND THERE'S BEEN NO
DOESN'T SPELL THIS OUT THE
CONSTITUTION YOU KNOW THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION ACTUALLY GIVE
STATES THE ABILITY.
TO SET THEIR OWN LEGISLATURE'S
AND IT ALSO GUARANTEES.
AN ARTICLE FOR A REPUBLICAN FORM
OF GOVERNMENT SMALL ARE THERE IS
IS WHAT I'M GOING TO HIM --
BUT REPUBLICAN FORM OF
GOVERNMENT IN A SYSTEM OF CHECKS
AND BALANCES --
AND GOVERNMENT NOW THAT LIKE WE
HAVE CREATED WITH THE US
GOVERNMENT SO.
THE CASE LAW THAT'S AND BEEN
INTERPRET OVERTIME AND PUBLIC
THE THE THE LANDMARK CASE FOR
OUR PURPOSES IS BAKER VERSES SR
BAKER VERSUS CARR AND THEN --
REYNOLDS VERSUS SIMS SAID THAT
STATE LEGISLATIVE DISTRICTS NEED
TO BE A EQUAL IN POPULATION
RIGHT.
AND THEN YOU KNOW THE ONE PART
ONE PERSON ONE RULE --
COUPLE THINGS [inaudible]
A ONCE SINCE THAT TIME THERE HAS
BEEN CASE LAW THAT SAYS THAT
THEY WILL ALLOW DEVIATIONS AND
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION TO CERTAIN PARTS
OF THE STATE'S OTHER WAS THE
ARAB BROWN VERSUS THOMPSON CASE --
IN --
WYOMING WHERE BASICALLY THERE
REDISTRICTING IN THERE SET UP
WAS THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY COUNTY HAD AT LEAST ONE
REPRESENTATIVE AND SO THEY HAD
STRUCTURED THEIR ASSEMBLY IN
THIS CASE.
SO THAT AT LEAST THAT COUNT THE
MOST RURAL COUNTY WOULD HAVE ONE
REPRESENTATIVE.
AND I DID THROW THINGS OFF KNOWS
MORE THAN THE 10% --
DEVIATION BUT THE COURT UPHELD
IT AND SO THERE HAS BEEN SOME
MOVEMENT TOWARD SAYING LOOK THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION --
WE WILL ALLOW SOME DEVIATIONS
EVEN DEVIATIONS GREATER THAN.
THAN 10% --
AN OUT AND OUT.
I WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT LOOK --
JUST BECAUSE A OF SUPREME COURT
HAS RULED THAT SOMETHING IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THAT COURT CAN'T SAME COURT
CAN'T.
EVOLVE AND CHANGE ITS MIND OVER
TIME ABOUT.
THE ISSUES OF REPRESENTATION NOW
IN THOSE CASES.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK IS ACTUALLY WRONG AS YOU
KNOW JUSTICE WARREN --
AS WE KNOW JUST OF ONE WAS WRONG
ABOUT LA THINGS INCLUDING
JAPANESE INTERNMENT --
BUT IN HIS.
IN HIS -- IN
HIS OPINION HE SAID.
LEGISLATORS DON'T REPRESENT.
BOB GRABBED THE LEGISLATORS
REPRESENT PEOPLE THEY DON'T
REPRESENT ACRES IN TREES.
I TAKE ISSUE WITH THAT.
BECAUSE LET'S THINK ABOUT THAT
FOR A SECOND --
I THINK VERY MUCH SO THAT WE
REPRESENT.
PEOPLE THAT REPRESENT TO YOU
SOMEBODY.
TAKE A VERY BIG THAT THAT SAY
THEY REPRESENT A PLACE RIGHT
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
NOT JUST THE PEOPLE AROUND THERE
THAT IT LEAGUE THE TEN THAT PART
BUT THEY REPRESENT THAT PLACE --
PEOPLE THAT REPRESENT THE GREAT
PORT OF OF LONG BEACH RIGHT --
OUT ANY OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL IT SAID TAKE PRIDE IN
THE IN THE FACT THAT THAT IS
THAT IS A PLACE THAT IT IS A
PLACE OF GREAT INDUSTRY AND SOME --
AND AND ECONOMIC BENEFIT TO THAT
REGION YOU KNOW IT'S NOT JUST
THE PEOPLE BUT IT'S THE INDUSTRY.
RIGHT -- I
THINK THAT --
WOULD SAY YOU KNOW THE THE BAY
YOU KNOW AND AND THE HEALTH OF
THE DAY.
RIGHT IS SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO PLACES NOT A SURLY
PEOPLE --
BUT WE DEFINITELY ABOUT THAT AND
FOR MY AREA THE ACRES OF
FARMLAND THAT FEED PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
OUR IMPORTANT AND THAT AND THE
TREES I'M I'M GLAD THAT YOU
ACTUALLY NO TREES IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE LIKE I SAID TREES ARE
PRETTY IMPORTANT.
HOW WE MANAGE OUR FORCE
[inaudible]
IS IMPORTANT IT'S LEADING THE
HUGE CARBON OUTPUT BECAUSE OF
THESE FORCE FIRES.
AND IT'S IT'S BEEN OF THE HAMPER
TO THE ECONOMY OF THOSE NOR
STATES NOT BEING ABLE TO DO
RESPONSIBLE TIMBER HARVEST.
AND IN THE NORTH STATE AND SO
YET TREES ACTUALLY MATTERS QUITE
A BIT ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AND THE ACRES AND ACRES OF
WATERSHED --
THAT I REPRESENT.
IS PRETTY IMPORTANT TO THE
ENTIRE STATE
AND HOW THAT'S MANAGE IN AND
WHAT AND AND HOW THAT GOES INTO
SO YES PEOPLE DO REPRESENT ACRES
ENTRIES AND THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I THINK IT'S
AN YOU KNOW OUR AS WE KNOW OUR
SUPREME COURT CAN INVOLVE.
AND IT CAN AND ITS MIND CAN
CHANGE ON DIFFERENT ISSUES I
THINK THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
THAT REPRESENTATION IS MORE THAN
JUST ENSURING EQUAL POPULATIONS
ANY TO EACH DISTRICTS LET ME
GIVE YOU ANOTHER.
QUICK EXAMPLE VERY QUICKLY IS
COMPLETE VERY QUICK VERY QUICK
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER THE
DRAWING OF YOUR MIND EVERYBODY
DRAWING OF A MAJORITY.
THE DRAWING OF MAJORITY MINORITY
DISTRICTS HAS BEEN RULED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BY THE SUPREME
COURT.
HOWEVER.
THAT HASN'T STOPPED US FROM
SAYING LOOK CAN WE FIND WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT MINORITY COMMUNITIES
ARE ABLE TO ACTUALLY LEFT.
PEOPLE OF THAT REPRESENT THEIR
INTERESTS IN THEIR DISTRICTS
RIGHT THAT HASN'T STOPPED US
FROM DOING THAT IT WAS RULED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL WE FOUND WAYS
TO STILL DRAW DISTRICTS.
THAT HELP ENSURE THAT MINORITY
COMMUNITIES THOSE MINORITY
VOICES HAVE A BETTER CHANCE OF
GETTING HEARD.
I THINK WE CAN DO THE SAME THING
WITHIN THE PARAMETERS OF SUPREME
COURT.
OF TRYING TO GIVE GREATER VOICE
TO ALL PARTS OF THE STATE.
AND SO THAT'S YOU KNOW.
LOOK AT I AT THERE ARE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES THERE BUT
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME
THIS BODY SAID HEY YEAH I KNOW
THE COURT SAID THIS IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BUT WE'RE GONNA
WORK TOWARD SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK IS A MORE JUST
[inaudible]
SYSTEM.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WHICH ARE STEINORTH AND
YES I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR MEMBERS SUCH AS A
CREATIVE --
YOU KNOW IT'S FUNNY SO I GET
ASKED I THINK WE ALL DO WHEN WE
GO BACK TO OUR DISTRICTS ON A
REGULAR BASIS WHAT'S IT LIKE IN
SET LIKE IN SACRAMENTO THE
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE TWO
POLITICAL PARTIES.
AND AYE I LIKE IN AND TRY TO
POINT OUT THAT IT ISN'T REALLY
ABOUT REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH
NORTHERN CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE URBAN AND
THE COASTAL AND THAT WE HAVE THE
INLAND.
AND FRANKLY ALL OF US ARE AT
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES OF HOW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NEEDS
OPERATE BASED ON THE GEOGRAPHIC
REGIONS AND THE THE COMMUNITIES
OF INTEREST THAT ARE WITHIN OUR
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS AND SO --
I APPLAUD THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
TAKING A STAB AT TRYING TO BRING
CHECKS AND BALANCES TO A SYSTEM
WHERE WE'RE NOT LOOKING
COMPLETELY THAT.
THE TYRANNY OF THE MAJORITY AND
ALL ASPECTS OF CALIFORNIA SO
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION TO MOVE THIS BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
MR HARBOR.
THANKS VERY MUCH PA AND I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS YOU'RE
BRINGING FORWARD I THINK YOU
IDENTIFY --
RIGHTLY A INITIATIVE WAS HIT --
RIGHT ON THE HEAD BY ASSEMBLYMAN
STEINORTH AND THAT'S THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE FEEL DISAFFECTED DIE
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THEY FEEL.
ODD THAT THE REGION'S THAT MAYBE
RICH WITH POPULATION AYE SUCH AS
THE BAY AREA OR LOS ANGELES.
OUR GOVERNING THE STATEMENT HE
HANDED WAY I THAT THAT DOESN'T
WORK OFTEN RESPECT THE FREEDOMS
FOR THE RIGHTS --
OF PEOPLE IN REGIONS THAT ARE --
OF DIFFERENT FOR PERSPECTIVE
THAN THEM AYE.
AND IN A SITUATION UP WERE IT
JUST SIMPLY AS MAYBE NOT
YIELDING TO A LOCAL CONTROL THEY
CAN PERHAPS I'D BE MORE
BENEFICIAL IN TERMS OF GOVERNING
POP PARTICULAR AREAS
[inaudible]
I I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
SOLUTION ALBEIT LAYING OFF ON
THIS TODAY.
ARE BUT I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND
YOUR REASONS FOR BUT I WOULD
NOTE -- THAT
THOSE HAVE WHO ARE OBJECTING ON
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSIDERATIONS
JUST KEEP HIM BEHIND THAT
USUALLY DOESN'T US THOUGHT THIS
LEGISLATURE FROM PASSING BILLS --
WE JUST SAW THE US SUPREME COURT
JUST YESTERDAY UP OVERTURNED I
AB SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE VIA WHAT
WAS CALLED THE FACT ACT WHICH
WAS THE OF FORCED ABORTION
REFERRAL.
A LINE CORSA NOT WAS UNCLE
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
SARACENO --
I DON'T THINK THAT'S NECESSARILY
THE OBJECTION PEOPLE SHOULD
THROW OUT A WHEN THEY VOTE FOR
THINGS LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR.
THE MISTER GALLAGHER WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE.
YES SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I AND I DO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE
I HOPE I I I REALLY HOPE PUT
ASIDE THIS DOES IS YOU EVEN IF
YOU DON'T SUPPORT THIS THIS
LEGISLATION YOU KNOW THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT TODAY.
AND THEY IT'S BRASIDAS GUSHING
ABOUT HEY HOW DO HOW DO WE
MODERNIZE OUR REPRESENTATION --
YOU HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT TIME.
A YOU KNOW THAT REALLY THAT ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE I THINK YOU
CAN IT WE CAN PROBABLY AGREE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S SO BIG IN ITS
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
WE REALLY ARE LIKE A NO A SERIES
OF STATES WITHIN A STATE YOU
KNOW BUT WELL BUT ALL OF US
TOGETHER ARE PART OF THE
GREATNESS A CALIFORNIA RIGHT
WERE PART OF WHAT MAKES A GREAT
AND IT IN IT IF THAT'S TRUE.
THEN HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS MORE OF A YOU KNOW
THAT EACH PART EACH PART OF THE
STATE WHICH YOU KNOW YOU CAN SEE
I THINK WE CAN ALL SAY LOOK THAN
THAT.
THESE DIFFERENT REGIONS THEY ARE
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S
DIFFERENT ISSUES THERE THERE'S
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT --
HOW DO WE GIVE THEM MAYBE MORE
OF AN EQUAL PLACE AT THE TABLE
WHEN IT COMES TO LEGISLATION AND
AGAIN I'M NOT ASKING THAT MY STE
THAT MY REGION GET TO DOMINATE
RIGHT?
I MEAN THIS WOULD GIVE MY REGION
AN EQUAL PLACE AT THE TABLE IN
THE SENATE THE ASSEMBLY WOULD
STAY THE SAME IS STILL BE BASED
ON POPULATION NOPE NO
LEGISLATION [inaudible]
COULD PASS AND BE ENACTED INTO
LAW WITHOUT GOING THROUGH THE
POPULOUS BODY.
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND WE WOULD
JUST HAVE AN A A DIFFERENT
STRUCTURE SET UP FOR THE OTHER
HOUSE MEAN.
SOME PEOPLE OFTEN ASK WHY DO WE
HAVE TO HOUSES IF THEY'RE BOTH
BASED ON POPULATION WHEN I JUST
HAVE A UNICAMERAL.
LEGISLATURE THERE'S YOU KNOW
THERE'S A BIG STEP OF OUR
PROCESS WE ALL WE ALL SCRAMBLING
AROUND RIGHT NOW.
GOING TO SEND THINGS BACK AND
FORTH AND IN A LOT OF WAYS OUR
JOB IS VERY SIMILAR WE REPRESENT
BASED ON POPULATION.
YOU KNOW I MEAN SO THERE'S
ARGUMENTS ABOUT THAT BUT LET'S
LET'S SPUR THAT DISCUSSION OF
BUT CERTAINLY WE CAN DO BETTER
THAN.
A WHAT WE CAME UP WITH AN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS THE
ONLY THING THAT WORKS AND LET'S
JUST KEEP.
GOING ALONG THOSE LINES I THINK
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THAT AND
AND I WOULD JUST ASK DOESN'T
LOOK IT MAY REQUIRE.
THE MEDICINE WITH THIS.
IT MAY REQUIRE.
URBAN AREAS TO TAKE A LITTLE BIT
OF A STEP BACK SO THAT OTHER
VOICES CAN BE HEARD.
BUT IS THAT SUCH A BAD THING AND
LET'S REMEMBER A LOT OF WHERE
THE POPULATION BASE IS IN LOS
ANGELES.
THAT HAS BEEN MADE VIABLE BY.
THE STATE WATER PROJECT RIGHT
WHICH BRINGS WATER FROM THE
NORTH DOWN TO THE SOUTH AND HAD
THAT NOT BEEN THE CASE IT COULD
NEVER SUPPORT THAT POPULATION
HAD NOT ALL THE BOND PAIRS THE
TAXPAYERS A CALIFORNIA PAID FOR
THAT.
THAT WOULD NOT BE THE CASE TODAY
RIGHT SO WE ALL KIND OF DEPEND
ON EACH OTHER.
AND SINCE ALLOWED ECONOMIC
GROWTH IS GONE TO THAT AREA LOT
OF THE BENEFITS YOU KNOW
ECONOMICALLY THAT I WOULD SAY MY
DISTRICT HAS MISSED OUT ON TO
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A STEP BACK
SO THAT OTHER VOICES CAN BE
HEARD SO OTHERS CAN HAVE AT
LEAST AN EQUAL.
PLACE AT THE TABLE IS SOMETHING
TO BE THINKING ABOUT AND IF WE
DON'T.
MY FEAR IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE MORE OF THESE MOVEMENTS --
TO TO SPLIT THE STATE I MEAN WHY
NOT BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO WILL WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
BEING HEARD --
THEY TEND TO SAY LOOK IT'S TIME
FOR US TO YOU KNOW.
GO OUR OWN SEPARATE WAY.
NON AND MAYBE YOU KNOW MAYBE
THOSE MOVEMENTS WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT BUT ELISE THIS
WOULD HELP US TRY TO ADDRESS I
THINK DOES VERY LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS IN ALL PARTS OF THE
STATE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU --
MISTER GALLAGHER AND YOUR YOUR
DISTRICT AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND RURAL CALIFORNIA ARE LUCKY
TO HAVE --
SOMEONE REPRESENTING THEM WITH
YOUR PASSION AND YOUR
INTELLIGENCE --
AND YOUR PERSEVERANCE --
I DON'T I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE POINT THAT YOU'RE MAKING --
WITH WHICH IS THAT WE ARE VERY
DIVERSE DAY AND I REPRESENT
SILICON VALLEY.
OUT TO THE COAST --
AND SO I HAVE FACEBOOK AND
GOOGLE AND I HAVE A GOAT GARY
THAT I HONORED AS MODEL SMALL
BUSINESS OF THE YEAR --
LAST WEEK --
AND SO.
I'M CONSTANTLY TELLING MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE AND AB ALSO HAD
THE THE THE GOOD FORTUNE OF
LIVING IN SOUTH DAKOTA --
FOR OVER YEAR --
BACK IN BETWEEN COLLEGE AND LAW
SCHOOL -- IN
AREAS THAT MAKE YOUR AREA LOOK
URBAN --
WINNER SOUTH DAKOTA POPULATION --
THREE THOUSAND BEING THE BIGGEST
CITY FOR A NINETY MILE RADIUS --
BUT THE FOLKS AND AND WINNER
SOUTH DAKOTA DIDN'T [inaudible]
BECAUSE THE FOLKS FROM THE URBAN
AREAS OF SOUTH DAKOTA AND THEN
THE FOLKS IN THE RURAL AREAS --
SHARED MORE IN TERMS OF THEIR
IDEOLOGY ON ON CERTAIN ISSUES
AND SO ON THE U. NO THEY THEY
EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE THE
SIMILAR ISSUES.
THAT THAT YOU'RE MENTIONING
TODAY THEY DIDN'T FEEL LIKE THAT
THE I THINK --
YOU MENTIONED THAT THIS WILL BE
MODERNIZING OUR OUR
REPRESENTATION SYSTEM BUT BUT I
THINK.
TAKING A SYSTEM THAT WAS CREATED
NOTHING YOU SAID EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT AND MAKING IT LOOK
LIKE A SYSTEM THAT WAS CREATED A
HUNDRED YEARS EARLIER --
IN THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTIES WITH
TO THE WAY THE US SENATE SYSTEM
IS SET UP ISN'T MODERNIZING
ANYTHING --
IT'S ACTUALLY GOING BACK --
TO DECISION THAT WAS MADE BASED
ON FACTORS THAT I THINK A LOT OF
YOU KNOW OUR STAINS ON THIS
COUNTRY --
THAT GUERRA WE DETERMINED THAT
THE SENATE REPRESENTATION BASED
UPON TO MOLLIFY STATES OF THAT
HAD PRACTICES THAT WE NOW LOOK
AT AS A WARRANT --
AND SO AYE I'M YOU KNOW I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE
REGIONS --
WE NEED THE PEOPLE ON THE URBAN
AREAS TO GO OUT TO THE RURAL
AREAS AND UNDERSTAND THE VALUE
THAT'S BEING CREATED.
WE ALSO NEED TO FIND WAYS. TO UP
LEFT TO THE RIVER THAT OR THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND AND GET
GOOD MANUFACTURING JOBS AND GET
YOU KNOW GOOD TECH JOBS --
AND AND FIND WAYS TO EXPAND THE
ECONOMY THAT'S MADE CALIFORNIA
SO STRONG --
TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA --
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THAT THIS
MEASURE --
IS THE WAY TO GO ABOUT THAT I
THINK THIS MEASURE DOESN'T
ENSURE QUALITY I THINK IT
ACTUALLY CREATES.
A INEQUALITY IN REPRESENTATION --
THIS MEASURE DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST SOME CAL POLITICAL
REPRESENTATION --
GIVING OTHER CALIFORNIANS MORE
THAN SIX TIMES THE VOTING POWER.
IT'S EXACTLY THIS TYPE OF
DISCRIMINATION THAT THE US
SUPREME COURT HAS MADE CLEAR IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND EVEN IF IN
WARRANT UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND YES --
OF THE NEW MAKE UP OF THE CORD
THAT WAS DETERMINED BY THE U. S.
SENATE IN THEIR INTRANSIGENCE IN --
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AN
UNWILLINGNESS TO ACTUALLY DO
THEIR JOB --
HAS CREATED A SITUATION WHERE --
MAYBE THIS WOULD BE DEEMED
CONSTITUTIONAL BY THIS CURRENT
SUPREME COURT WHO KNOWS I'M NOT
INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT --
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS I'M
UNABLE TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE --
AND RECOMMEND A NO VOTE BUT
DEFINITELY DO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THIS CONVERSATION --
AND AND FINDING WAYS THAT WE CAN
INCREASE.
WELL UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE
REGIONS OF OUR REALLY DIVERSE
STATE BECAUSE NOT MY
CONSTITUENTS HAVE GOTTEN TIRED
OF ME TELLING THEM THAT WHEN I
WENT OUT TO VISIT --
MODESTO --
MODESTO REMINDED ME A LOT MORE
SOUTH DAKOTA THAN IT DID SILICON
VALLEY --
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT ALL OUR
REGIONS --
ALL ART ARE CALIFORNIANS
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE REALLY
BIG DIVERSE STATE AND THAT WE
RESPECT OUR DIFFERENCES.
ARE A AND AND WORKED.
TO OUR UP LEFT EVERYBODY --
AS WELL SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRING THIS FORWARD I'D I DON'T
SUPPORT IT --
BUT I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING MORE COVER --
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AT THE MOST S. B. ADOPTED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN NO BERMAN
NO HARPER.
HARPER NOT VOTING CALDERON
[inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN NO STEINORTH STEINORTH
[inaudible]
I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER NO [inaudible]
IT.
BUT SURELY THAT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SUPERVISOR AT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER TALK
ABOUT YOU ALL TO COME UP THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ABSOLUTELY
FINE WE CAN HAVE TECH JOBS WHO
HAVE BEEN NO INFRASTRUCTURE TO
GET THERE ARE NO IT
MANUFACTURING HAVE NO.
WORDS TO GET BACK OUT SO WE GOT
WORK TO DO WHEN WE LIVE RIGHT
NEXT TO WHERE WILL THAT LEAVE IT
UP WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
GUYS GOT NORTH I I'D LOVE TO BE
THAT.
WILL BRING IT UP YOU CAN'T YOU
CAN'T IS NICE WILL TAKE YOU A
LITTLE FARTHER GO UP INTO
SISKIYOU IN AND MODOC AND REALLY
SEE WHY.
THE STRUGGLES OF OF A LOT HAVE
YET TO SEE DELMIA OKAY SO THAT
ON THE FOURTH WE TOUR SO THEY'VE
THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN UP TO
MACLEOD PLAN ON DOING THAT TOO
THAT'S PRETTY HIT WE YEAH.
ALRIGHT YEAH YEAH BICU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SO IN.
WAS THE TO TELL ME YEAH I THINK
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT.
OKAY NOT FREE AND I WAS GONNA
THAT'S YOU'RE PUTTING IN YOUR
OFFICE.
I'LL COME OVER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
STEWART IS WAY DOWN AUTHORS
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
SIR.
YOU ARE UP [inaudible]
WITH.
I DON'T WERE THREE SB
[inaudible]
TWENTY FIVE WE READY. ONE OF YOU
ARE SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY NKING
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING --
DILIGENTLY WITH MY STAFF ON
AMENDMENTS.
I AND FOR THE RECORD I'LL BE
TAKING THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS --
ALSO MY STATEMENT WILL REFLECT A
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS I THINK
IT IMPROVES THE BILL SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU --
TODAY IN PRESENTING S. B..
TWENTY FIVE WHICH REVISES THE
BALLOT ORDER --
MANY PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY UP TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
DISCRETION --
THE BALLOT ORDER --
SO THE PROPOSED BALLOT OR WOULD
PUT LOCAL CITY SCHOOL.
AND PROPOSITIONS FIRST FOLLOWED
BY A COUNTY OFFICES FOLLOWED BY
STATE AND THEN FOLLOWED BY
FEDERAL WHICH TO ME MAKES
SENSORS THE OLD ADAGE ALL.
POLITICS ARE LOCAL PEOPLE --
HAVE AN IMMEDIATE AFFINITY FOR
THEIR LOCAL ELECTED IN MANY OF
US HAVE SERVED IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THINK THIS IS A
WELCOME ADDITION --
TO THE POLITICAL PROCESS THE
AMENDMENTS IN THIS BILL REQUIRE
THE BILL TO BE A PILOT PROGRAM
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY FROM
JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THROUGH.
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AND SUNSET
AFTER THAT THE AMENDMENTS ALSO
PERMIT LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
CONTINUE TO USE THE SAME BALLOT
ORDER AFTER.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO IF THEY
CHOOSE TO DO SO AND LASTLY THE
BILL REQUIRES A REPORT. TO BE
SUBMITTED BY THE LA COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL. TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE EFFECT ON THE
AFFECT OF THE NEW BALLOT ORDER
WHICH IS SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT I KNOW TO THE CHAIR
WANTED TO COLLECT THE DATA WHICH
I THINK MAKES THIS A STRONGER
BILL --
MEMBERS THE PROPOSED LAWS IN
EFFORT TO BOOST TURNOUT IN LOCAL
ELECTIONS WHICH AS WE ALL KNOW
THE LEGISLATURE BY MOVING STAND
ALONE ELECTIONS. TO CONSOLIDATE
THE GOAL WAS TO TRY TO INCREASE
LOCAL TURNOUT THE THE CONCERN
THEM BROUGHT TO ME BY NUMEROUS
CITY COUNCILS --
AND SCHOOL BOARDS AROUND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHICH AS YOU KNOW
I THINK THEY'RE EIGHTY EIGHT
CITIES OUTSIDE OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES --
WERE THAT THEY WERE CONCERNED
THEY GET LOST IN A LONG BALLOT --
AND SO OUR MOVE MIGHT HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT TO TURN OUT
SO THIS IS AN EFFORT WE KNOW
PEOPLE ARE GONNA GO DOWN BALLOT
TO VOTE FOR THE PRESIDENT OR
GOVERNOR THIS AN ATTEMPT. TWO
OUT TO ADDRESS THAT THE ISSUE
WAS BROUGHT TO ME BY CITY CLERK
OF ONE OF THE LARGEST CITIES IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FROM GLENDALE
MY FRIEND ARTICLE SAKE AND
SUGGESTED THE IDEA AS A CITY
CLERK INSIDE HERE HAVE HIM HERE
TO TESTIFY BEHALF THE BILL SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MY NAME IS
ART EXCITING AND I AM THE
ELECTED --
CITY CLERK OF GLENDALE
CALIFORNIA IS MY PLEASURE TO BE
HERE WITH YOU THIS MORNING --
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND TO
THE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
SENATOR I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON S. B. TWENTY FIVE AS
YOU CONSIDER IT IN THE FUTURE OF
LOCAL ELECTIONS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO GIVE A
SPECIAL THANKS TO SENATOR
ANTHONY PORTANTINO WHO LENT A
WILLING EAR TO THE CONCERNS OF
MANY LOCAL RESIDENTS
CONSTITUENTS AND OFFICIALS IN
THE WAKE OF THE PASSAGE ADOPTION.
OF LAWS THAT HAVE CHANGED THE
WAY LOCAL CITIES AND
JURISDICTIONS CONDUCT THEIR
ELECTION.
TODAY I'M SPEAKING TO YOU AS THE
CITY CLERK WHO HAS NOT.
LOCALLY --
FOR STATE OFFICE AND HAS WORKED
VOLUNTEERED AND ADVISED ON
CAMPAIGNS ELECTIONS AND
GRASSROOTS VOTER OUTREACH
PROGRAMS.
AS MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE WHEN
THE STATE'S VOTERS RIGHTS
PARTICIPATION ACT WAS ADOPTED
AND SIGNED INTO LAW IT PROMPTED
MANY CITIES.
AND WHICH HAD THEIR OWN
STANDALONE ELECTIONS TO
CONSOLIDATE WOULD STATEWIDE
ELECTION DATE.
IN GLENDALE WHAT THAT MEANT WAS
THAT OUR TRADITIONAL DATE OF
APRIL ELECTIONS HELD BIENNIALLY
IN ODD NUMBERED YEARS HAVE NOW
MOVED TO COINCIDE WITH EVEN
NUMBERED STATEWIDE ELECTIONS.
WHICH INCLUDE PARTISAN OFFICES
AND MANY OTHER OFFICES INCLUDING
JUDICIAL SEATS AND STATE
PROPOSITIONS.
THE INTENT OF THE BILL WAS TO
HAVE LOCAL ELECTIONS WITH
RELATIVELY LOW VOTER TURNOUT
COINCIDE WITH ELECTIONS
APPRECIATE A MUCH HIGHER TURNOUT.
BUT TURNOUT ISN'T JUST A MATTER
OF DATES DURING STATE AND
NATIONAL ELECTIONS A LOT OF
FUNDS.
ARE SPENT BY ORGANIZATIONS
PARTIES AND CANDIDATES RUNNING
ON PARTISAN ISSUES.
AND TICKETS TO REACH VOTERS.
AND RIGHTFULLY SO SINCE THIS IS
A DATUM OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS BUT FOR THE AVERAGE
CITIZEN WHO HAS NEVER RUN FOR
ANY OFFICE.
LOCAL OFFICES AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW SINCE THAT IS WHERE THE
BACKGROUND OF MANY PEOPLE WHO
RUN FOR HIGHER OFFICE COMES FROM
ITS CITY COUNCIL SCHOOL BOARD OR
OTHERWISE.
THIS IS THEIR FIRST INTRODUCTION
TO RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
LOCAL ELECTIONS TEND TO BE FOR
THE MOST PART NONPARTISAN AND
OFTEN THESE CANDIDATES ARE
UNABLE TO COMPETE FOR FUNDS.
WHEN THERE ARE BIGGER RACES
GOING ON?
EVERYONE I'M SURE HAS HEARD AND
IS VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE TERM
DONOR FATIGUE IN THIS ROOM.
NOW PICTURE THE IMPACT ON THIS
ON LOCAL CANDIDATES AS THEY TRY
TO CUT THROUGH THE NOISE OF
MAILERS AND OTHER CHALLENGES AS
A RUN FOR THEIR LOCAL OFFICES TO
BETTER THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
PARTISAN ELECTION CYCLES. TO GET
THEIR MESSAGE OUT TO THE VOTERS.
WE ARE ASKING YOU TO CHANGE
THINGS BACK TO THE WORD THE WAY
THEY WERE BUT MERELY ASKING YOU
TO CONSIDER SIMPLE COMMON SENSE
BILL THAT WOULD REVERSE THE
ORDER OF THE BALLOT.
AND MOVIES OFTEN FORGOTTEN RACES
RELEGATED TO THE BALLOT BOTTOM
OF THE BALLOT BOOK TO THE FRONT
OF THE BOOK WHERE THEY WILL DRAW
THE ATTENTION OF THE VOTERS.
WHO GO TO VOTE?
IN A RESEARCH STUDY CONDUCTED BY
PROFESSORS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
PITTSBURGH AND PUBLISHED BY THE
LONDON SCHOOL OF ECONOMICS IT
WAS CITED THAT LOWEST LEVELS OF
ROLE OFFICE.
AS WOULD LOS LEVEL OF RELAPSE
WAS 11% OF VOTERS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TOP OF THE
TICKET ELECTIONS AND FAILED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE DOWN TICKET
RACES.
AND IT'S IS AS HIGH AS 21% THAT
WAS BASED ON PARTISAN
AFFILIATION.
RESULTS SUGGEST SEVERAL
PHENOMENON MAY BE INFLUENCING
VOTER PARTICIPATION WHEN THEY GO
TO THE POLLS.
ROLOFF MAKER BECAUSE VOTERS MAY
BECOME FATIGUED WE'VE OFTEN
HEARD OF VOTER AND ELECTION.
OF FATIGUE.
BY THE TIME THEY REACH A JUICY
JUDICIAL RACES THEY MAY HAVE
VOTED IN SO MANY OFFICES ALREADY
THAT THEY SIMPLY CANNOT BE
BOTHERED TO INVEST MORE TIME IN
THE PROCESS.
AND MOST LOCAL RACES ARE NOW
FOLLOW THE JUDICIAL RACES.
SECOND ROLL OFF MAY STEM FROM
IGNORANCE VOTERS MAY REACH DOWN
TICKET RACISM WHICH THEY KNOW
LITTLE IF ANYTHING ABOUT THE
CANDIDATES AND CHOOSE NOT TO
VOTE BECAUSE THEY LACK ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO DO SO.
THIRD AUTHORED OF ALL ROLOFF
MAKER BY ACCIDENT AND IT MAY BE
THAT SOME VOTERS USE A STRAIGHT
TICKET VOTING OPTION AND DO NOT
REALIZE THAT IN DOING SO THEY
HAVE SKIPPED THE NONPARTISAN
OFFICES WHICH IS WHAT MOST LOCAL
OFFICES ARE.
HOW THE STATE STRUCTURE THAT'S
ELECTIONS IN BALLOTS CAN IMPACT
WHICH OF THESE PROCESSES IF ANY
MAY BE AFFECTING VOTERS THIS IS
WHAT SB?
TWENTY FIVE WILL HELP US STUDY
AND HOPEFULLY REALIZE WHAT JERRY
WAS WHILE THE GOAL OF THE
RESEARCH IS NOT TO SETTLE THIS
DEBATE OVER ADOPTING A CERTAIN
TYPE OF ELECTION ARE BALLOT.
THE RESULTS WILL CLEARLY SHOW
THAT THAT THIS IS WITH THESE
RESULTS OF THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT THERE CLEARLY --
IMPACTS AND CONSIDERABLE
CONSEQUENCES OF HOW WE DESIGN OR
BALLOTS ELECTION SYSTEMS I
BELIEVE THAT ANY PERCEIVED
CHALLENGES CAN BE ADDRESSED BY
THE MODERNIZATION EFFORTS TO THE
VOTING SYSTEMS.
THAT THE LA COUNTY REGISTRAR IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ON TO THE V.
SAP PROJECT AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ALLOW LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND ANY
OTHER COUNTIES WILLING TO SEEK
THIS OPTION TO RECONFIGURE THEIR
BALLOT ORDER. TO MAKE THOSE
LOCAL OFFICES BEFORE ALL OTHER
OFFICES ON THE BALLOT ALONG WITH
THE SENATOR I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
OF SUPPORT PRESS BE.
TWENTY FIVE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU TO
IMPROVE OUR ELECTION SYSTEM AND
DEMOCRATIC PROCESSES THANK YOU
MISTER I CAN'T.
BUY ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CARE ROTH ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY'S A PASADENA AND
BURBANK BOTH IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KURT BLACKBURN OF
ELSA WILSON ADVOCACY HERE ON
BEHALF THE CITY OF LOCKING OUT
OF FLINTRIDGE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PLUG
INS OFFICE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF SIRI DOSE
NORWALK SIGNAL HILL AND THOUSAND
OAKS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A GOOD MORNING I RYAN RUN GO BY
CO CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATION
COMMITTEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COURSE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS WERE NOT IN OPPOSITION.
JUST WANTED TO MENTION THAT WERE
TWEETERS HERE WHERE I JUST
BRINGING UP SOME CONCERNS.
I VERY --
THANKFUL TO CENTER PORTANTINO TO
ADDRESS OUR FOR DRESSING THE
ISSUE OF BALLOT DROP OFF AND I
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING TAKEN.
BY TO MAKE THIS A PILOT --
WELL WE'RE NOT OPPOSING THE BILL
AYE WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL FIRST OFFICE
FLEXIBILITY.
BY DOESN'T SOUND LIKE AT LEAST A
FROM WHAT I HEARD IN THIS
DISCUSSION I'D THAT ASIDE THE
ISSUE OF FLEXIBILITY HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS HAVE SOME LIMITED
FLEXIBILITY WITH MOVING SOME
CANDIDATES AROUND OR AND SOME
RACES AROUND.
AT THAT FLEXIBILITY SAVES MONEY
BY GIVING US THE ABILITY --
TO I REDUCE THE NUMBER BALLOT
CARDS I MIGHT BE USED IN AN
ELECTION.
ADD IF I EXPAND THEIR IS --
A SIMILAR CONSIDERATION OF BURKE
THERE'S I'VE WE DON'T SEE ANY
SUMMER CONSIDERATION OF
FLEXIBILITY IN THIS PROPOSAL.
I SECONDLY BALLOT HEADERS ARE
CONTEST HEADERS AT THIS PROPOSAL
CREATE SOME NEW FAQ CONTESTS
HEADERS THAT WE NOW NEED TO
ADDRESS.
AND ANYTIME THAT WE REMOVE A
REALISTIC FROM THAT BALLOT WE
HAVE A CONCERN ALSO ESPECIALLY
GIVENTHE LACK OF FLEXIBILITY ON
MOVING CONTESTS AROUND.
I'D THAT THAT COULD CREATE A
SOME ADDITIONAL COSTS BECAUSE WE
NOW HAVE MORE ROOM TAKEN UP BY.
THE HEADERS AND NO FLEXIBILITY
SO WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
POSSIBLY ADDRESS AND THEN
THIRDLY OUTREACH A SOMEONE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO HELP EDUCATE
THE VOTERS ABOUT THIS CHANGE.
AYE IT'S A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
OBVIOUSLY.
A THE AUTHOR HAS TOLD US THAT
THE COMMITTEE ARE COMMITTEE THAT
HE INTENDS TO ADDRESS EDUCATION.
BUT WE DON'T SEE THAT IN THE
CURRENT VERSION THE BILL DIDN'T
HEAR IT MENTIONED.
IN THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE JUST
DISCUSSED FOR THAT BURDENS GOING
TO FALL ON SOMEBODY AND WE THINK
THAT THAT'S GOING TO FALL ON THE
LOCAL ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
A IT SO THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT CONCERN ADDRESSED AS
WELL I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I RESPOND YEAH
AND ONE SECONDS BY THE ANSWER
HINES YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR A
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
DELEGATE IS THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT I'M SORRY I'M LATE I WAS
RUNNING FROM ANOTHER COMMITTEE --
WE WE SUPPORT THE EFFORT TO ING
INCREASE --
VOTERS IN OUR ELECTIONS AND TO
ADDRESS THE DROP OFF IS SPECIAL
DISTRICTS RIGHT NOW WE'RE ON THE
BOTTOM OF THE BALLOT.
BY THE TIME VOTE THERE SO MANY
PEOPLE DROP OFF A A LOT OF OUR
ELECTIONS ARE GONNA WILL ONLY
HAVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE VOTING
IN THE AFFECTED WERE FOR GOD
MATTER DROPS UP SO MUCH THAT
HAVE WHEN THIS BILL WAS IT
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED.
WE WEREN'T EVEN IN IT --
HOWEVER AFTER THE AMENDMENTS WE
WERE PUT BACK INTO WHERE WHERE
HIGHER UP WHERE THE SECOND
SECTION.
AYE WE BELIEVE THIS WILL
INCREASE TO A VOTER TURNOUT IN
OUR LOCAL ELECTIONS AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AND THEN BRING BACK TO COLLEGE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BUT
CENTER IF YOU LIKE DID.
THEY GET COULD HAVE HIDING IDA I
WOULD LIKE JUST BOND INSTEAD OF
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
A PUNCH CARD.
IT HAS NUMBERS FROM ONE TO
WHATEVER [inaudible]
THOUSAND IT'S LIKE PUNCH CARD
EVERY SINGLE ELECTION.
A DIFFERENT VALUE GETS ASSIGNED
TO A DIFFERENT BUBBLE I GUESS IN
SOME RACES YOU MIGHT HAVE A
CONTESTED.
ASSEMBLY PRIMARY THERE MIGHT BE
FIFTEEN CANDIDATES SO IN THAT
PARTICULAR RACE FROM.
ONE TO FIFTEEN IS A SUPPLY IS
ASSIGNED TO ON AND ELECTION SO
WITHIN EVERY ELECTION AND THE
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES CHANGES SO
THE COMPUTER ASSIGNS A DIFFERENT
VALUE TO EACH BUBBLES SO.
FAR AS THERE BEING ANY SORT OF
INCREASED COST TO DO THAT.
THAT'S HAPPENS FROM ELECTION
ELECTIONS WHETHER THIS BILL
BECOMES LAW WHETHER IT DOESN'T.
BUBBLE ASSIGNED FOR THE COMPUTER
SCIENCE VALUES TO BUBBLES THAT'S
ONE NUMBER TWO AS THE STATE
MANDATED THIS CHANGE THOSE
BALLOTS IN THOSE HATTERS HAVE TO
CHANGE ANYWAY.
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THE HEAD OF
THAT CHANGE LET'S?
DO THIS AT THE SAME TIME SO WE
THINK THAT'S A PRAGMATIC --
THING TO DO THE OTHER PIECES
HARD EDUCATION YES WE'RE GONNA
HAVE AN EDUCATION CAMPAIGN AS
PART OF A BUT THAT'S ALSO WHERE.
THE CITIES THAT COMMENT IF YOU
NOTICE MOST OF THE CITIES IN LA
COUNTY AS WELL AS THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES THE CALIFORNIA CONTRACT
CITIES ASSOCIATION.
ALL OF THE ADVOCACY GROUPS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE ALL PART
AND PARCEL TO THE SUPPORT OF
THIS AND ARE GOING TO BE DOING
THEIR OWN CAMPAIGN TO EDUCATE
THEIR VOTERS AS WELL SO.
THIS IS A TRUE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AT TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN SO I AM I THINK WE WE
HAVE ADDRESSED THE THIS FARCE
THE FLEXIBILITY ISSUE I ACTUALLY
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY LANGUAGE ON
THAT -- BUT
I'M HAPPY TO LOOK AT IF THERE'S
AYE IN AGAIN WITH THE WE ON THIS
[inaudible]
SUGGESTION ON PRUDENT
FLEXIBILITY FOR ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS I'M I'M OKAY WITH THAT
BUT THE BASIC CONCEPT IS.
LET'S USE THE STATE LAW.
THAT IS INTENDED.
TO CREATE A HIGHER TURNOUT TO
ACTUALLY SEE THAT WE HAVE A
HIGHER TURNOUT PROBABLY ON THESE
LOCAL ELECTIONS THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES AND QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS VICE YOUR HARPER
[inaudible]
WHY [inaudible]
WELL IF YOU'RE RUNNING FOR LOCAL
OFFICE IN A CYCLE WHERE THERE
HIGHER OFFICES THAT ARE ALSO ON
THE BALLOT --
AND OBVIOUSLY THERE IS REQUIRES
FUNDS TO RUN FOR OFFICE A LEASE
FOR MOST OF THE OFFICES --
THAT WHETHER IT'S THE CITY
COUNCIL SCHOOL BOARD. TO GO TO
THE TO DRAW FROM THE SAME POOL
TO GO TO TO CUT THROUGH THE
NOISE -- TO
SEND OUT MAILERS --
TO PRINT OUT LAWN SIGNS --
IF THEY'RE ALSO INDIVIDUALS
RUNNING.
FOR ASSEMBLY CONGRESS SENATE
WELL ETCETERA A IT SOMETIMES
BECOMES DIFFICULT FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS RUNNING FOR LOCAL
OFFICES TO DRAW FROM THOSE
SAMPLES OF SUPPORT --
SOME PEOPLE MAY NOT BE WILLING
TO DONATE TO THE LOWER TICKET
RACES.
IT IS THE IT IS THE POINT
THEREIN THAT THERE MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH MONEY IN LOCAL POLITICS.
NO I I I I THINK WHAT HE'S
TRYING TO SAY IS WHEN YOU MOVE
FROM A STAND ALONE ELECTION
[inaudible]
WHETHER THAT'S YOU KNOW.
THE POLITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
WHETHER THAT'S THE ATTENTION OF
THE VOTER WHEN YOU MOVE FROM A
STANDALONE ELECTION WHERE YOU'RE
THE ONLY GAME IN TOWN. TO A
BALLOT WHERE THERE'S EVERY
SINGLE THING UNDER THE SUN.
THERE'S NO VOICE.
AND THE LO THE THE LOCAL VOICE
WHICH IS MAYBE BE A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER.
MAY BE A SCHOOL BOND.
OR A THE INITIATIVE WHATEVER
THAT IS THAT LOCAL EFFORT IS
GOING [inaudible]
TO PETE.
WITH THE PRESIDENTIAL THE
GUBERNATORIAL.
STATEWIDE SO ALL OF THOSE OTHER
THINGS AND THAT NO WAYS
SOMETIMES WILL DROWN OUT THE THE
LOCAL EFFORTS I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S THE POINT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HARPER LET ME PUT IT DIFFERENTLY --
MAKE SURE BUT LET ME JUST SAY
THAT -- SO I
FLEW UP HERE THIS MORNING ON
SOUTHWEST I WISH I COULD HAVE
BROUGHT WITH ME F. FROM THE LAST
TWO GENERAL ELECTION CYCLES THE
VOLUME OF MILLER'S I'VE RECEIVED
FROM CANDIDATES RUNNING. FOR
OFFICE IS HIGHER THAN LOCAL
OFFICE BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S
A LIMIT ON HOW MUCH I CAN CARRY
AND I DIDN'T WANT TO BURDEN
MYSELF IN BRINGING THAT AMOUNT
OF MAIL WITH ME TO BRING IT TO
YOU. TO SHOW YOU WHAT
INDIVIDUALS RUNNING FOR OTHER ON
THE SHOULD HAVES AND FOR EVERY
OTHER OFFICE.
NOW FOR LOCAL OFFICE NOT ONLY IS
IT DIFFICULT TO JUST RAISE MONEY
IF YOU'RE A NOVICE TO THE
PROCESS.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT --
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
MAILERS ARE SEEN IN AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED ANNA AND
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THERE'S
ALREADY ALTHOUGH OTHER
INFORMATION THAT'S OUT THERE
THAT'S COMPETING FOR THE EYES
AND EARS AND ATTENTION OF THE
VOTERS.
THANK YOU FOR POINT I THE NEXT
ONES OF FOR THE AUTHOR.
I'M TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHAT
EXACTLY THAT YOU'RE IDENTIFYING
AS THE PROBLEM BECAUSE I HEARD
TERMS LIKE VOTER TURNOUT.
UP BUT THEN FROM THE WITNESS AYE
WE HEARD.
ABOUT ROLL OFF A ABOUT PEOPLE
VOTING IN.
A FEDERAL OFFICES BUT MAYBE NOT
A REACHING LOCAL OFFICES ONCE
THEY GET THAT DOWN THE BALLOT SO
IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY.
WHAT IS THE PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE IS IT THE NUMBER
OF BALLOTS CAST BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT I USUALLY UNDERSTAND TO
MEAN?
BY VOTER TURNOUT OR IS IT.
TRY TO MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF
VOTES THAT ARE MADE FOR LOCAL
OFFICE GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
BALLOTS WHAT'S THAT. TO
DETERMINE SUCCESS WHAT IS THE
NUMERATOR AND WHAT IS THE DID A
DENOMINATOR IS IT IS IT BALLOTS
CAST I IS IT I THE PERCENTAGE
THAT YOU HAVE THAT HER.
I THINK THE MORE DIRECT HERMES
UNDERVOTES.
ARE THAT THERE ARE FOR LOCAL
OFFICE VERSUS BALLOT CAST OR IS
IT UNDERVOTES OBVERSES TOTAL
VOTING AGE ELIGIBLE POPULATION.
PLEASE HELP ME IDENTIFY WHAT'S
THE PROBLEM IT'S HARD UNDERVOTES
THAT IS THE PROBLEM AND AND THE
THEORY IS THIS.
PEOPLE WILL GO JUST LIKE WE KNOW
IN A GENERAL ELECTION MORE
PEOPLE SHOW UP IN A GENERAL
ELECTION BECAUSE THEY'RE OUT TO
VOTE FOR THE PRESIDENT OR
THEY'RE OUT TO VOTE FOR THE
GOVERNOR.
THE NAY VOTE IN A PRIMARY --
MANY PEOPLE GO IN AND THEY JUST
VOTE FOR THE PRESIDENTIAL CAN'T
CANDIDATE OF THEIR CHOICE AND
THEY GO HOME THEY DON'T GO DOWN
BALLOT.
SO THE THEORY IS THIS.
PEOPLE SINCE WE'RE CONSOLIDATING
THE ELECTION WE BELIEVE AS WELL
AS MOST OF THE COUNTIES IN OR TO
BE CITIES AN ALLEY COUNTIES
[inaudible]
THEY BELIEVE COLLECTIVELY THAT A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
WILL NOT GO DOWN BALLOT AND VOTE
FOR EVERY SINGLE.
ELECTION ON THAT BALLOT BECAUSE
THEY'LL STOP AFTER THE HIGH
PROFILE ELECTIONS SO WE BELIEVE
THERE WILL BE SIGNIFICANT
UNDERVOTES.
AND THAT CONTRADICTS THE THEORY
OF CONSOLIDATING THE ELECTIONS
IN THE FIRST PLACE BECAUSE THE
GOAL WAS TO INCREASE TURNOUT ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
CONVERSELY WE BELIEVE THAT WHEN
PEOPLE OPEN UP THEIR BOOK AND
THEY SEE THEIR LOCAL SCHOOL
BORDER THEIR LOCAL MAYOR THEIR
LOCAL.
SCHOOL PARCEL TAX WHATEVER IT IS.
THEY'LL DO THE LOCAL RACES AND
THEY HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO GO
DOWN TO VOTE FOR THE PRESIDENT
THEY'RE NOT GONNA GO THERE NOT
GOING TO VOTE ON THE LOCAL
ELECTION AND GO HOME.
THEY'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO THEY
GET TO THE HIGH PROFILE ACTIONS.
WE BELIEVE THAT IS GOING TO BE
THEIR BEHAVIOR WE THINK THAT
SERVES DEMOCRACY IN THE CITIES
AND WE ALSO BELIEVE IT SERVES
DEMOCRACY FOR THE FOR THE STATE
AND AND FEDERAL LAW ELECTIONS AS
WELL.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO WE'RE GONNA DO A LOT A CITY
SECTION.
I COUNTY SECTION.
STATE SECTION AND A FEDERAL
SECTION IT ACTUALLY FOLLOWS A A
LOGICAL ORDERLY PROGRESSION OF
THOUGHTS.
AND WE THINK THAT MATCHES
[inaudible]
THE VOTERS.
MENTALITY AS WELL THE GONNA
THINK LOCAL THAN THE GONNA GO
COUNTY.
STATE AND FEDERAL.
YEAH IF I COULD ASK TO CLARIFY I
WITH THE AMENDMENTS AS A PILOT
PROJECT.
WHAT WHAT IS THE TIMEFRAME THAT
WE HAVE HERE IS IT THAT THE
BALLOT ORDER IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS GOING TO FLIP OVER
420-002-02020 AND THEN IT WILL
FLIP BACK IN LESS AYE?
FURTHER LEGISLATION IS THE IDEA
IS TO PROVIDE DATA FROM BOTH A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND THEN
AN OFF YEAR ELECTION SO THERE
WOULD BE TWO CYCLES.
SO WE WOULD GET THE DATA FROM
TWO CYCLES.
A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND THEN
A GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION WE
THINK THAT'S A PRUDENT.
STEP AND THEN FRANKLY WE'RE
TRYING TO EMPOWER THE LOCAL SO
IF THE COUNTY REGISTRAR LIKES
THIS.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE
SOMETHING THEY LIKE.
BUT IF THEY DECIDE THEY DON'T
LIKE IT.
IT WOULD SUNSET AND I WOULD GO
BACK WOULD REVERT BACK.
SO WE THINK IT GIVES THE DATA
THAT.
EVERYBODY WANTS WE THINK IT WILL
SOLVE THE PROBLEM THAT WE THINK
EXISTS AND WE THINK THAT'S A
PROPER COMMONSENSE CONCLUSIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I
IF I MAY MENTION.
LA I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION ON THAT WAS MADE --
THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE OF
COURSE ARE SWITCHING ELECTION
ORDERS AND THEN POTENTIALLY
SWITCHING BACK I THINK THAT
COULD LEAD.
TO AYE A GREATER DEGREE OF A OF
VOTER CONFUSION --
ESPECIALLY THE TIME WHEN IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AYE WE JUST HAD A
SITUATION WHERE I THINK WAS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE --
WERE LEFT OFF THE VOTER ROLLS OR
WE'RE HAVING CHALLENGES IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO VOTE SO I'M NOT
SURE IF LOS ANGELES COUNTY --
IS THE RIGHT LOCATION OUGHT TO
DO THIS IF IT WAS WORTH WHILE TO
DO A HIM ON A PILOT PROJECT.
I WOULD COUNTER UP PROPOSE A
THAT I THINK THAT THE ISSUES
THAT ARE BROUGHT UP ARE VALID
POINTS.
I THAT THERE ARE IS A LOT OF
NOISE AND IT'S VERY HARD TO
DIFFERENTIATE YOUR RACE --
WIN NOW THERE'S ALL THESE
FEDERAL AND STATE RACES THEY'RE
GOING ON IVERSON'S LOCAL
ELECTIONS AND SO I THINK THAT --
A PROPOSAL THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISH THAT IS FAR SIMPLER
AND NOT SIMPLY BY REPEALING AYE
S. B. FOUR ONE FIVE FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN THAT FORCES LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
BY TWO I HAVE THESE ELECTIONS
AND INSTEAD ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE
FREESTANDING ELECTIONS AND THAT
WAY I THINK THAT YOU'LL GET WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING --
FOR WHICH IS TO HAVE OUR FEWER
UNDERVOTES.
UP MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE TURNING
OUT TO PARTICIPATE ARE
PARTICIPATING IN ALL THE
ELECTIONS ON THE BALLOT.
AND WERE AVOIDING VIA THE NOISE
SITUATION WHERE I'M MAILERS
MAYBE DISTRACTING OR OTHER
FACTORS MAY BE DISTRACTING AND I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD SOLVE THE
ISSUE.
I AM PERHAPS OF BRINGING FORWARD
IN THE IN THE NEXT --
SESSION I WOULD BE AN
OUTSTANDING IDEA --
I JUST THINK THAT THERE'S A
DIFFERENT SOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER MULLIN.
THANK ASSURE THANK YOU SENATOR A
VERY INTRIGUED BY THEIR SAY WILL
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE PILOT TO
SEE WHAT THAT DOES IN TERMS OF
HOW BALLOT DROP OFF WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE I KNOW THAT
LOS ANGELES WILL AT SOME POINT I
HOPE -- BE.
OPTING AND ON THE VOTERS CHOICE
ACTON GOING TO ALL VOTE BY MAIL.
SO THE COMBINATION OF GOING TO
ALBANY BY MAIL WHICH IS HAVING
SIGNIFICANT I IMPACT ON TURNOUT.
LAW AND SWITCHING THIS BALLAD
ORDER YOU MAY REALLY SEE I
IMPROVE PARTICIPATION IN THE
LOCAL.
OUR OFFICES WHO A LOT HAPPENING
HERE -- I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE PILOT --
A MY ONE QUESTION WELL WHAT MY
ONE RESERVATION I GUESS WOULD BE
AND THIS IS WHY WE'RE DOING A
PILOT IN ITS EXPERIMENTAL IS YOU
KNOW DO YOU HAVE A SCENARIO
WHERE VOTERS ARE SKIPPING OVER.
THE LOCAL TO THE HIGHER PROFILE
RACES AND NOT RETURNING.
OUGHT TO TO THE DEL MAR
LOCALIZED RACES BUT WILL LEARN
THAT ARE IN THE PILOT WHEN YOU
COMPARE TYPICALLY VS ELECTION
CYCLES SO I AM VERY INTRIGUED BY
THIS I WILL SUPPORT IT IF IT
DOESN'T HAVE A MOTION ALL MOVE
IT. ONE QUESTION NO.
DOES THE DECEIT ULTIMATE
DECISION IN THE COUNTY RIVER TO
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
TO CONTINUE THE PILOT OR IS THAT
JUST A DECISION ARE TO BE MADE
BY THE LOCAL REGISTRAR.
I WAS ANTICIPATING THE REGISTRAR --
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE CHIEF
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL --
AND THAT WAY IT'S NOT PART OF
THE POLITICAL PROCESS BUT IF YOU
HAVE A BETTER IDEA.
YOU KNOW.
I JUST THINK THAT'S THE PERSON
WHO'S ENTRUSTED WITH MAKING THE
DECISION --
I'M FINE WITH THAT I'M FINE WITH
THAT'S MY THUMB I JUST WAS
CURIOUS IF IT WAS CALLED OUT OF
THE BILL SO MAYBE TO AN AWKWARD
IF YOU DID NOT SEE THAT
AMENDMENT SO --
WE CAN CLARIFY THAT TO ME.
THAT'S MY THINKING THAT THE
CHIEF ELECTIONS OFFICIAL.
THE WHO'S GONNA HAVE THE MOST
IMMEDIATE.
UNDERSTANDING OF WHETHER THIS
WAS SUCCESSFUL OR NOT AND THEN
IT WOULDN'T BE POLITICAL THAT
WOULD BE MY SUGGESTION.
IN THEM MY ONLY COMMENT THERE
WOULD BE IF YOU CAN CONFER WITH
THE LOGAN ABOUT THAT AND AND THE
CLERKS.
TICKET FOR THAT THAT'S THEIR
CHOSEN APPROACH --
BUT WITHOUT ALMOST THE BILL
WOULD IT'S REALLY MOTION THE
SECOND.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SENATE PORTANTINO GEORGIA CLOSE
JUST THAT I THINK THE
CONVERSATION IS IMPORTANT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT VOTER
TURNOUT AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR WHO FROM LAST YEAR HAS
SHOWN AN INTEREST IN.
TRYING TO MOVE THIS ALONG TO GET
THE DATA THE SO WE CAN WELL
SERVE THE PUBLIC SO WITH THAT
SPECULATES WHEN I DON'T.
THINK YOU THE US AND THERE AND
AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THAT THAT WE'VE HAD
TODAY I THINK NO QUESTION WAS
RAISED THERE WITH THIS ADDRESS
UNDER VOTE.
OR WITH THIS ADDRESS VOTE
TURNOUT OR WHAT'S THE GOAL HERE --
AND AND I THINK THE THE ANSWER
WAS RIGHT WOULD BOTH GOALS ARE
GOOD GOALS AND WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO PASS POLICIES IN
THIS BODY.
THAT TRY --
TO BOTH INCREASE TURNOUT AND
INCREASE --
AND AND DIMMITT AND AND KIND OF
LESSON OF THE UNDER VOTING THAT
DOES OCCUR FOR LOCAL RACES IN
DOWN BALLOT RACE ISN'T SO I
THINK THE COMBINATION OF PRIOR
LEGISLATION.
THAT WAS PASSED BEFORE I WAS
HERE A IN ADDITION TO THIS TODAY
AND AND OTHER EFFORTS THAT WILL
HELP TRY TO GET TO THAT --
YOU KIND OF OVERALL OVERALL GOAL
THAT WE HAVE OF EVERYBODY VOTING
ON EVERY RACE --
THAT DIED REPRESENT THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT THE AUTHOR
AND I HAD SENT A PORTANTINO AND
I HAVE HAD ABOUT THIS --
IT'S IT'S REALLY INTRIGUING IS
REALLY INTERESTING --
IDEA -- I I
GOT MENTIONED YA PRIVATELY I WAS
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH A PILOT
PROJECT IN A GATHERING AS MUCH
DATA AS POSSIBLE TO SEE WHAT
IMPACT IT HAS REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SENDER AND WOOD --
BEING WILLING TO GO THAT ROUTE --
AND YEAH.
YOU KNOW WITH THAT SAID I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL SO
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO CALDERON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
SO THAT'S OUT ON THE FOUR ONE
VOTE WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR US
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE SIR.
PRESENTING SB.
SEVEN FIFTY NINE YOU CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY NAY NO IT'S
BEEN VERY BUSY FOR ALL OF YOU
AYE AND APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE TO START OUT
TODAY MISTER CHAIR BY ACCEPTING
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT WAS
IT THANK YOU SIR FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK AND YOUR AMAZING STAFF.
PIE THEY ARE FANTASTIC BICU TO
WORK WITH THANK YOU SO MUCH I A
STRONG DEMOCRACY AT THE BEGIN
ALL AGREE DEPENDS ON A VOTERS
BELIEF THAT THERE BALLOT COUNTS.
HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA ACCORDING
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
OVER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS HAD THEIR WORLD ROCKED
AYE WHEN THEY'RE BALLOT WAS
THROWN AWAY NOT COUNTED IN THE
NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION.
BECAUSE OF IN THIS MATCHING
SIGNATURE.
HOW CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY ALLOWS
EIGHT DAYS TO CORRECT A BALLOT
WITHOUT A SIGNATURE THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE THAT IT COUNTY GIVES A
VOTER AN OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT
IN THIS FASHION SIGNATURE?
IN FACT THAT HE SAID TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
THEIR BALLOTS TOSSED IN NOT
COUNTED BECAUSE THEY WERE
NOTIFIED OF A DISCREPANCY IN
THEIR SIGNATURE.
S. B. SEVEN FIFTY NINE CREATES A
PROCESS FOR LOCAL LUCK AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO NOTIFY
VOTERS WHEN THEY'RE VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS INJURE MISMATCHES THE
ONE ON FILE.
IT ALSO GUARANTEES THOSE VOTERS
INOPPORTUNE TO CORRECT THAT
MISMATCH SAID THEIR VOTES CAN BE
COUNTED.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY
CANDIDLY A BALLOT HAS IMAGE
MADNESS MATT SIGNATURE IT COULD
BE BECAUSE A PERSON HAS A
DISABILITY.
UPPER SIX SIGNATURE MAY CHANGE
OVER TIME.
AS SOMEONE MISUNDERSTOOD IN
SIGNED IN NON ENGLISH CHARACTERS
OR DIFFERENT MEMBER OF THE
HOUSEHOLD SUCH AS A SPOUSE OR
CARETAKER.
SIGN THE BALLOT ON THEIR BEHALF.
IN ITS RECENT HEADLINES HAVE
SHOWN EVEN ONE VOTE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE VIRGINIA HOUSE RACE
IS A PRIME EXAMPLE.
AS THE HOUSE AS THE USE OF VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOTS INCREASE IN
CALIFORNIA WE CANNOT IGNORE THIS
ISSUE ANY LONGER.
IN TODAY OVER HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS VOTE BY MAIL A IN
SOME COUNTS CONDUCT ENTIRE
ELECTIONS BY MAIL.
THE MOST RECENT SET OF
AMENDMENTS REFLECT OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
REGISTRARS AND ONCE A THANK YOU
FOR THAT WORK.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
AND ONCE HE THANK YOU TO THE
SECTOR STATE HIS TEAM OP FURTHER
LEADERSHIP AND OF COURSE THE
ACLU UP FOR THEIR AYE
TRAILBLAZING LEADERSHIP.
IN THE STATE ON THIS ISSUE.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO NOTIFY
VOTERS OF MISMATCHING CINCTURE.
IT THE SAY DAYS PRIOR TO
CERTIFICATION OF AN ELECTION A
GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE A
TO VERIFY THAT SIGNATURE.
THE VOTER RETURN TO SINK A
VERIFICATION A STATEMENT KNOW
MAY LATER THAN FIVE PM TWO DAYS
PRIOR TO THE CERTIFICATION OF
THE ELECTION.
THEIR REQUIRES AN ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL TO PROCESS OUR BOAT BY
BATMAN.
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT PROPERLY.
AND AGAIN I WANNA SAY THANK YOU
OUGHT TO THE CHAIR OUT FOR HIS
WORK ON HELPING BRING US
TOGETHER THE STAFF AS WELL AS
ALL THE STAKE HOLDERS AND WOOD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD IN
FOREIGN AYE VOTE TODAY A WE HAVE
TIFFANY MARK MISTER CHAIR CHIEF
OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
OFFICES FACTORIES STATE.
IN MY ANGER AND I WHO IS A
LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY WITH THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AYE IT WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TO KEEP
DEMOCRACY STRUCK.
THE CENTER.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
IF YOU MOCK ME HAVE FOR
SECRETARY STATE EXPEDIA WE'RE
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL GONNA
THINK OF THE STAFF SUPPORTERS
AND FUTURE SUPPORTERS FOR THEIR
DEDICATION TO CRAFTING A BILL
WHICH IS OPERATIONALLY POSSIBLE
AND MEETS THE THRESHOLD OF OUR
KEY SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MANGUM ACLU
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT WE
WITNESS THE PROBLEM WHEN.
BALLOTS ARE DISREGARD FOR
SIGNATURE MISMATCHES AND OUR
RESEARCH WE FOUND THAT ASIAN
AMERICAN VOTERS LATINO VOTERS
AND VOTERS BORN OUTSIDE THE U.
S. WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISENFRANCHISED BY IS PERCEIVED
SIGNATURE MISMATCHES.
AND BRING IN OUR LAWSUIT WE
RECEIVED A FAVORABLE COURT
DECISION AND WE THINK THAT THIS
BILL IS A GREAT EFFORT AND
CODIFYING THAT COURT DECISION TO
ENSURE THERE'S CONSISTENT
APPLICATION.
STATEWIDE AND VOTERS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CARE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE.
THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY THAT AWARENESS IS IN SUPPORT.
ANDREAS FISCHER WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING HIM BACK TO
COLLEGE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION.
VICE CHAIR HARPER [inaudible]
YES.
VERY MUCH ON MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
IT WOULD MAKE IT VERY EASY FOR
AN UNSCRUPULOUS PERSON TO CHEAT
BY SENDING IN A FAKE SIGNATURE.
BY WHICH WOULD OF COURSE
DISENFRANCHISED BY EACH OF THE
OTHER LEGITIMATE VOTERS.
I IS YOU MAY KNOW THE BIPARTISAN
NATIONAL COMMISSION ON FEDERAL
ELECTION REFORM WARNED THAT
STATES.
I A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO THAT THE
GROWING YOU QUOTE THE GROWING
USE OF ABSENTEE VOTING HAS
TURNED THIS AREA VOTING INTO THE
MOST LIKELY OPPORTUNITY. FOR
ELECTION FRAUD NOW ENCOUNTERED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS ON
QUOTE AN OCCASSION STATES TO
LIMIT OPPORTUNITIES FOR VOTE BY
MAIL ABUSES.
ELECTION LAW EXPERT PROFESSOR.
RICK HASTEN THE CHANT FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE UP PROFESSOR
OF LAW AT UC IRVINE SCHOOL OF
LAW HAS NOTED THAT A SMART WAY
TO QUOTE STEAL AN ELECTION IS
THROUGH THE SALE OF ABSENTEE
BALLOTS.
THAT TRANSACTION CAN BE DONE IN
PRIVATE.
THE PERSON BUYING THE BALLOTS
CAN BUY BLANK ONES FROM CHEATING
VOTERS AND THE QUE AYE AND THEN
CAST THE BALLOTS HIMSELF OR
HERSELF.
THESE BALLOTS CAN SIMPLY BECAUSE
SIMPLY.
CAST BY SIMPLY MAILING THEM IT
IS EASY TO FIND CASES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY EVERY YEAR OF FRAUD
OR ATTEMPTED FRAUD WITH ABSENTEE
BALLOTS UNQUOTE.
WHEN PEOPLE SIGN THEIR VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT?
THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE AN ORIGINAL
SIGNATURE TODAY.
BUT UNDER YOUR BILL IF THE
SIGNATURE DOESN'T MATCH THE
VOTERS RECORDS SOMEONE COULD
THEN SEND IN A COPY.
OF THE VOTERS WRECKED SIGNATURE
BY EMAIL OR FAX.
THEY COULD PHOTOSHOP THE VOTER
SIGNATURE ONTO A VERIFICATION
STATEMENT AND THEN SEND A COPY
OF THE DOCUMENT BY EMAIL OR FAX.
AND SINCE IT WOULD BE A COPY I
FRAUD WOULD IN FACT BE
UNDETECTABLE.
SOLUTION I WOULD ASK IS WOULD
YOU BE WILLING TO AMEND THE BILL
TO REQUIRES THAT THE VOTER
RETURN THE FORM WITH AN ORIGINAL
SIGNATURE.
AND RETURNING THAT FORM EITHER
IN PERSON BY MAIL OR DELIVERY
SERVICE I'D DIE SPRUCE UP
PROVIDING THE SAME INTEGRITY AS
THE IS THE ACTUAL YOU KNOW WHAT
SIGNATURE.
AUDITS ON THE SAME UP BALLOT
ITSELF.
THROUGH THE CHAIR EMBASSY
THINKING THE VICE CHAIR FOR THE
COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T THAT WE'VE
BEEN THINKING A LOT ABOUT --
THIS LEGISLATURE AND IT ACTUALLY
INITIATED WITHIN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR PASSED
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY
ASSEMBLYMAN QUIRK --
AND CALIFORNIA LAW IN WE ALL
ACTUALLY VOTED ON IT EVERY
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE.
ALONG WITH MYSELF.
LET ALLOWS A VOTER WHO DID NOT
SIGN THEIR VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
TO RETURN A COMPLETED UNSIGNED
BALLOT STATEMENT.
BY EMAIL.
IT'S A LOT IN LITERALLY EVERYONE
OF US.
ARE DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS
SUPPORTED WHO ARE ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
SO THAT WOULD WELCOME ANY
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO BE A TO
STRENGTHEN THE LAW AND TO BE A
TO WORK ON THAT --
BUT THAT WE CODIFIED THE ABILITY
FOR VOTERS TO BE OF THE MOVE ARE
ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE FOR A
SIGNATURE VIA EMAIL FOR LAST
YEAR.
A IN WOULD WELCOME ANY
SUGGESTIONS IN THE FUTURE HOW TO
BETTER STRENGTHEN LA.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY I A FOLLOW
UP ON THAT.
I BELIEVE THAT IT'S A VERY
INCONSISTENT FROST REQUIRE A
VOTE BY MAIL ENVELOPES SIGNATURE
TO BE THE ORIGINAL BUT IF IT
DOESN'T MATCH.
I WHICH EVIDENCE THAT SOMEONE
ELSE CAN SIGNED IT THAT THEY CAN
SEND AN EMAIL COPY --
EMAILED A COPY OF THE VOTER
REGISTER A SIGNATURE WITH NO
GUARANTEE THAT THE REAL VOTER
HAS SIGNED THE FORM.
AND WHEN WE HAVE CLEAR EVIDENCE
OF VOTER FRAUD WE NEED REQUIRE
STRONG GUARANTEES. FOR THE
AUTHENTICITY OF A FOLLOW UP
SIGNATURE NOT WEAKER PROTECTION.
I I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS OF
THE AUTHOR HOUSE --
WITH TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE.
AND I'D BE ABLE TO VOTE FOR THIS
IF IT WAS REQUIRING AN ACTUAL
SIGNATURE BUT BECAUSE OF THE A
FAX OR COPY ISSUE.
BUT I CAN'T VOTE FOR THE BILL SO
I APPRECIATE THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO CLARIFY THAT ISSUE
FAMOUS RISE SHARE MISTER MULLIN.
THING WAS CHAIR AND THANK YOU
MISS REQUIRE FOR HOW.
PUSHING THIS ISSUE IT'S BUILDING
ON SOME LEGISLATION I HAD --
ON SIGNATURE VERIFICATION EN.
ARE AYE HAILED AYE COME FROM ONE
OF THOSE COUNTIES THAT IS IS
MOVING TO AN ALL VOTE BY MAIL.
MODEL HAS ALREADY MOVED TO AN
ALL MALE BALLOTS SO THIS WILL BE
AN INCREASING --
ISSUE THE IMPORTANCE SO MIGHT MY
ONLY QUESTION HERE IS WITH
REGARD.
TO THE V. SIGNATURES SHALL
COMPARE.
COMPONENT HERE.
THAT ULTIMATELY --
THIS THE UPDATED SIGNATURE IS
STILL COMPARED TO THE ORIGINAL
VOTER REGISTRATION CARD.
AND I GUESS MY CONCERN IS JUST
ABOUT WITH THE WHOLE A RANGE OF
ISSUES AROUND SIGNATURES A
EVOLVING OVER TIME --
IT'S STILL PAID BACK TO THAT
ORIGINAL VOTER REGISTRATION
WHICH MAY HAVE INSIDE WHEN THEY
WERE EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN ARE.
AND YOU KNOW.
HOPEFULLY THE REGISTRARS ARE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT TO OTHER
DOCUMENTS ON FILE THAT HAVE MORE
UPDATED SIGNATURES SO THERE MAY
BE NO WAY AROUND --
THIS ISSUE I THINK YOU'RE
PROBABLY ARE.
GETTING AT THIS THE BEST WAY
POSSIBLE WITH THIS OF
VERIFICATION STATEMENT US SO I
APPLAUD YOU FOR THE EFFORT.
I JUST THINK IT YOU KNOW THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE ISSUES THAT WILL
ALLOW.
YOU KNOW CONTINUE TO PERPLEX US
ODD GOING FORWARD.
ARE BECAUSE WE REALLY HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH --
BALLOTS SAID AND FOR ALL THE
REASONS YOU SITE BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT I THINK IT
BUILDS ON EXISTING EFFORTS AND
NOW I'M A PROUD TO SUPPORT IT
AND NOW.
HOPE TO WORK WITH YOU WHY TO
MONITOR THE SUCCESS OF THIS AND
SEE HOW WE MIGHT FURTHER REFINE
THE SIGNATURE VERIFICATION
PROCESS GO FORWARD.
THEY LOOK AT THROUGH THE CHAIR I
AYE IN ANNOUNCING THAT BECAUSE
THE SOMEONE IS HERE IN FRONT OF
US TODAY BUT I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THIS IN THE MEMBER SOME
NEVER MULLIN.
A FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND
YOU HAVE BEEN.
OUTSPOKEN IN ADVANCING
SUCCESSFUL LEGISLATION I'M AND
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH YOU WOULD BE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
OTHER YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
IT WOULD BE COMPARED TO THE ARE
THE CARD ON FILE.
ON I'LL A TRIP OVER THAT TIM'S
MY FIRM THE SECTOR A STATE
OFFICE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
ABILITY.
UP BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THE IN TRULY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AS WELL.
AND SO WE CAN LOOK INTO THAT AND
THE SPECIFIC CUTS ACTION WHICH
PROVIDES FOR HOW THE AFFIDAVIT
IS ON FILE IN THAT PROP.
CONSULTING WITH THE WRECKAGE
[inaudible]
ACTIVE.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
CENTER WHERE HE LIKE TO CLOSE
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR THINKING YOUR STAFF THANK
YOU THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
DISCUSSION TODAY AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I ABOUT.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRING THIS BEFORE --
TO I'D HAD A CHAT WITH WITH MY
STAFF ABOUT THE ISSUE THAT
MISTER MULLIN RAISED --
WHICH IS A INTERESTING ONE MY I
KNOW MY SIGNATURE IS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY SINCE I WAS
EIGHTEEN ERRED WILL EIGHTEEN I
WANT TO REGISTER TO VOTE BUT I
KNOW THAT --
THE AND IN THE BE --
OF MY SIGNATURE STILL PRETTY
SIMILAR --
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT A
LOT OF REGISTRARS WILL
SIMILARITIES --
TO TRY DE KIND OF VERIFY THAT
IT'S IT'S THE SAME SIGNATURE
JUST ADDRESSING THIS CONCERNED.
UP.
IN THE ABILITY TO UTILIZE THIS
FOR WIDESPREAD ELECTION IN
INFLUENCING IN AND HACKING --
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
RIGHT TO THE REGISTRAR WILL USE
THE CONTACT INFORMATION THAT IS
ON FILE. TO NOTIFY THE VOTER OF
THE MISMATCH IN SIGNATURE AND SO
IF SOMEBODY WANTED TO UTILIZE
THIS. FOR WIDESPREAD ELECTION
INFLUENCING --
THEY WOULD NOT ONLY HAVE --
TO SUBMITS A WHOLE LOT OF
BALLOTS BE ABSENTEE MAIL THAT
WOULD WOULD --
YOU KNOW KIND OF ADDRESS THEIR
THEIR GOAL BUT THEN THEY WOULD
ALSO HAVE TO INTERCEPT --
WHATEVER --
A COMMUNICATION HAPPENS FROM A
REGISTRAR TO THAT VOTER --
AND I THINK I WON THEIR LA
CONCERNS AROUND --
ALL THESE NEFARIOUS EFFORTS TO
INFLUENCE THE ABSENTEE.
NOW VOTING AND AND OTHER WAYS
THAT WE'VE THE POLICIES WE'VE
CREATED TO INCREASE TURNOUT THE
ONLY DOCUMENTED ELECTION
INFLUENCING ON A WIDESPREAD
SCALE THAT'S HAPPENED IN AMERICA
AND IN DECADES.
ALWAYS BY OF ON A MERE PUTIN IN
THE RUSSIANS TO SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THEY FOUND A
DIFFERENT WAY.
OUGHT TO INFLUENCE OUR ELECTIONS
THAT DID NOT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH ABSENTEE VOTING SO I HAVE
NO CONCERNS AT THAT THIS WILL
LEAD TO WIDESPREAD.
A HACKING AND I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
CENTER YOUR THINKING ON THAT I
WILL SAY ME.
BRIGITTE.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THIS AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE AYE.
BERMAN AYE HARPER.
HARPER NOW CALDERON CALDERON I
NO.
NO I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH STEINER'S
NO WEBER.
WEBER AYE [inaudible]
THAT'S THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
FIVE TO TO VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATE MCGUIRE.
SO WE HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL AND
THEN LIFT THE CALL ONE AND
NUMBER TWO A CA SIXTEEN BY
SOMEONE NUMBER GALLAGHER.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS ONE TO THREE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING NO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CALDERON.
CALDERON NO NO.
NO NO.
THAT BILL FAILS --
ON A ONE TO FIVE VOTE AND WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE --
OPEN THE ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ON ITEM ONE A. B. SIXTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT AYE.
CHAIRMAN BERMAN HARPER.
HARPER NOW CALDERON.
CALDERON I KNOW [inaudible]
SO I ON ITEM THREE SB TWENTY
FIVE BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE NO.
NO HONEY.
ITEM FIVE S. B. TWELVE THIRTY
NINE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG HARPER.
HARPER NO CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE NO NO I ITEM SIX S.
B. TWELVE FIFTY BY SENATOR
BRADFORD HARPER.
HARPER NO CALDERON CALDERON AYE
WELL.
NO I GREAT.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU VERY MUCH